oder eben auch nicht aufgerufen wir
hören mal rein
viele Menschen sind erschöpft und wir
alle wünschen uns eine möglichst
schnelle Rückkehr zu einem normalen
Alltag
eine Impfpflicht wirft fachlich
schwierige und rechtlich rechtlich wie
ethisch Kontroverse Fragen auf
sie zwingt uns zu komplexen Abwägungen
heute tauschen wir uns darüber aus was
für eine allgemeine verpflichtende
Impfung spricht und was dagegen
wir hören Vorschläge Bedenken Einwände
und sortieren Optionen ergebnisoffen
über Fraktionsgrenzen hinweg
bedenken wir dabei dass die Menschen in
dieser angespannten Zeit von uns vor
allem Orientierung erwarten
deshalb wünsche ich mir eine faire
respektvolle und konstruktive Debatte
die parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführerinnen und Geschäftsführer
haben sich darauf verständigt dass es in
dieser Debatte keine Kurzintervention
und keine Zwischenfragen geben soll
alle Abgeordneten deren redewünsche
nicht berücksichtigt werden können haben
die Möglichkeit ihre Redebeiträge zu
Protokoll zu geben
sind Sie damit einverstanden
das ist der Fall dann verfahren wir so
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
180 Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne hiermit die Aussprache das
Wort hat zu Beginn für die SPD-Fraktion
Dagmar Schmidt
also das ist eine
orientierungsdebatte auf drei Stunden
angesetzt noch ohne konkrete Vorlagen
erste Rednerin kommt von der SPD sagt
mal Schmidt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin froh
und dankbar dass wir die Debatte zu
Impfpflicht heute hier führen hier im
Parlament wo diese Debatte hingehört und
ich bin mir sicher dass der
demokratische Teil dieses Hauses sie
trotz aller Unterschiede sehr angemessen
und respektvoll führen wird
man kann sich irgendetwas selber
ausdenken
zusammenschwurbeln dabei immer gegen die
da oben hetzen und den Leuten dummes
Zeug erzählen das ist einfach und nutzt
allen denjenigen die das Vertrauen in
unsere demokratischen und
wissenschaftlichen Institutionen
zerstören wollen man kann es sich aber
auch
wie die allermeisten die anstrengende
Mühe machen Verantwortung zu übernehmen
abzuwägen
zu diskutieren immer wieder auf die
neuesten wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse
zu reagieren zu versuchen kompliziertes
einfach zu machen auch wenn uns das
nicht immer gelingt dabei müssen wir die
Sorgen und Ängste auf der einen Seite
aber eben auch die Erwartung an
konsequentes Handeln auf der anderen
Seite sehr ernst nehmen und deswegen
sollte uns alle ein Anliegen einen
nämlich dass wir noch mal einen großen
Anlauf machen aufeinander zugehen und
zum Impfen einladen dass wir überzeugen
Sorgen ernst nehmen und Fragen
beantworten
denn es ist kein kleiner Schritt wenn
lange Zeit eine Impfpflicht
ausgeschlossen wurde und diese dann doch
eingeführt werden soll warum ich es
trotzdem für notwendig halte will ich
kurz erläutern den in Wirklichkeit reden
wir ja nicht über eine Impfpflicht ja
oder nein sondern wir reden über
Alternativen im Umgang mit der Pandemie
und jede Entscheidung auch die dagegen
hat Konsequenzen zu denen man sich dann
eben auch bekennen muss und welche
Alternativen haben wir erste Alternative
es laufen lassen das führt irgendwann zu
einer grundimmunität vorher führt es
aber zu vielen Toten Kranken und
longkowid-patienten es führt dazu dass
Menschen wegen Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystems nicht mehr behandelt
werden können und zu unmenschlichen
Anforderungen an diejenigen die dort
arbeiten wir haben uns aus guten Gründen
bisher dagegen entschieden und auch
Omicron ändert daran nichts
die zweite Alternative um das Virus im
Griff zu halten kennen wir nur allzu gut
kontaktbeschränkungen
Zugangsbeschränkungen all die Maßnahmen
bis hin zum Lockdown
es droht also wieder ein Herbst und
Winter wie dieses und letztes Jahr nur
dass es jetzt wirklich an uns selber
liegt das zu ändern weil wir die Mittel
in der Hand halten und so komme ich zur
dritten alternative einer sehr hohen
Impfquote davon sind wir trotz aller
Bemühungen noch sehr weit entfernt und
deswegen brauchen wir für den Weg aus
der Pandemie eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
[Applaus]
die Impfstoffe die wir haben zählen mit
zu den besten überhaupt mit inzwischen
weltweit knapp fünf Milliarden geimpften
wissen wir das sehr gut nach dem Stand
der Wissenschaft bieten drei Impfungen
einen guten Schutz gegen schwere
Verläufe und Tod auch bei Varianten wir
kommen damit zu einer Grundimmunisierung
ähnlich wie bei der Grippe und viele
haben diese auch schon wir wollen alle
ab 18 einbeziehen damit alle mit allen
solidarisch sind die mit mehr Kontakten
mit denen die ein größeres Risiko haben
und umgekehrt
wir wollen
eine Auswahlmöglichkeit für die
Impfstoffe und Ausnahmen für die die
sich aus medizinischen auch psychischen
Gründen nicht impfen lassen können und
wir wollen bei der Durchsetzung eine
Balance halten zwischen ernsthafter
Durchsetzung mit Nachweispflicht und
Bußgeldern weil wir eben sonst das Ziel
nicht erreichen aber wir wollen dabei
die Verhältnismäßigkeit bewahren die
Impfpflicht ist ein milderes Mittel als
die Gefährdung der Gesundheit durch
Durchseuchung und auch als weitere
Einschränkungen die vor allem Kinder und
Jugendliche aber viele andere mehr
Treffen mit harten Folgen psychischen
Folgen vergangenen Lebenschancen
finanziellen Problemen Zukunftsängsten
wir haben einen Weg aus der Pandemie der
heißt impfen damit wir wieder
damit wir wieder unbeschwert Freunde
sehen uns umarmen Kunst und Kultur
genießen feiern singen und tanzen können
ich freue mich drauf
drei gruppenanträge sind in Vorbereitung
im Wesentlichen ein Gruppenantrag für
eine Impfpflicht ab 18 dem sich auch
hier Dagmar Schmidt angeschlossen hat
ein Gruppenantrag für eine Impfpflicht
ab 50 und ein Gruppenantrag der eine
Impfpflicht eine allgemeine ablehnt die
Abgeordneten haben sich allerdings noch
nicht alle entschieden die Union
beispielsweise hat vor dieser Debatte
kurz vorher angekündigt dass sie sich
heute das anhören wird und dann einen
eigenen Antrag vorlegen will
der Gesundheitsminister hat das sich ja
geweigert einen konkreten Vorschlag zu
unterbreiten und deshalb finde ich die
orientierungsdebatte auch vor dem
Hintergrund sehr interessant dass uns
vielleicht heute verraten wird wie sein
Antrag aus einem Vorschlag genau
aussehen könnte ich glaube 80 Millionen
Menschen interessiert das in Deutschland
auch und insofern möchte ich auch im
Vorfeld meiner Rede noch kurz darauf
hinweisen dass es wirklich schade ist
dass auch hier bei diesem Thema was wir
heute in einer orientierungsdebatte hier
diskutieren keinerlei
ich sage jetzt mal Richtung auch das
Bundeskanzlers oder auch das
Gesundheitsministers vorgegeben worden
es ist erinnert mich so ein bisschen an
Versteckspiel man spielt solange
verstecken und hofft dass irgendjemanden
Konzept zur Impfpflicht vorlegt wenn man
nur lange genug darauf wartet und
deshalb meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
möchte ich auch noch mal in den Kontext
darauf hinweisen dass wir als Union
diese Debatte hier sehr begrüßen aber
wir hätten uns gewünscht dass wir diese
Debatte schon viel viel früher geführt
hätten nämlich vor Weihnachten als wir
einen langen Fragenkatalog an das
Bundeskanzleramt geschickt haben wo wir
im Vorfeld dieser Debatte gern einfach
mal gewusst hätten wie bestimmte Fragen
auch seitens der Bundesregierung
einsortiert werden denn die Fragen ja
muss man sagen sie sind gestern
beantwortet worden und auf die 22 22
wichtigsten Fragen wurden sag und
schreibe 12 Zeilen geantwortet also
insofern liebe Kolleginnen und
Kolleginnen frage ich wie ist das der
Anspruch der Bundesregierung ich hoffe
nein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Gesundheitskrise in der wir uns befinden
hat historische Ausmaße und deshalb ist
es ja auch so wichtig dass wir uns
überlegen wie können wir aus dieser
Pandemie herauskommen und deshalb ist es
im Rahmen dieser debat auch noch mal
ganz ganz wichtig voranzustellen dass
impfen der Weg aus der Pandemie ist und
insofern ist es ja deshalb auch so
wichtig dass wir uns darüber
verständigen wie denn eine Impfpflicht
aussehen könnte und nicht nur
plattitüten in den Raum stellen sagen
allgemeine Impfpflicht keine Impfpflicht
was auch immer sondern dass wir uns
darüber verständigen wie wir diese
Impfpflicht ausgestalten können und
deshalb liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lassen Sie uns auch die fachlichen
Bedenken ernster nehmen das hätten wir
uns gewünscht im Vorfeld der Debatte
dass wir auch Fragen eingehen wie kann
so eine Impfpflicht ausgestaltet werden
auch verfassungsrechtliche Fragen
spielen eine Rolle Juristen sagen uns
vor dem verfassungsrechtlichen
Hintergrund vor den Voraussetzungen ist
es eben doch nicht so einfach zu sagen
wir machen eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
ohne zu erklären wie denn diese
Impfpflicht aussehen könnte die
Mediziner bei uns impfen schützt bei
Corona wir wissen aber mittlerweile dass
die Impfstoffe nach einer gewissen Zeit
an Wirksamkeit verlieren das sind alles
Punkte die wir diskutieren hätten müssen
bereits im Vorfeld das sind alles Punkte
die uns die Bürger jeden Tag Fragen und
niemand gerade bei den Bürgern hat Lust
sich alle drei Monate oder alle vier
Monate Boostern lassen Boostern ohne
Ende kann nicht die Option sein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und deshalb
möchte ich auch noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass die pauschalen Lösung
fast immer die schlechtesten Lösung sind
und deshalb sollten wir auch in der
Debatte differenzieren es muss doch
gerade darum gehen neben der Frage des
ob einer Impfpflicht auch zu diskutieren
wie denn diese Impfpflicht aussehen
könnte und das sollten wir genauer
hinschauen wie könnte das denn passieren
da hätte ich mir gewünscht dass der
Bundesgesundheitsminister nicht nur in
Talkshows eine Meinung äußert und sagt
allgemeine Impfpflicht sondern dass er
auch mal sagt wie stellt er sich das
denn vor geht es dabei um konkrete
Gruppen wie ist das Risiko zu bewerten
einzelner Risikogruppen wie ist die
Variante Omicron vor dem Hintergrund der
Hospitalisierung zu bewerten zeitliche
Komponenten und nochmal wir brauchen ein
ordentliche Datengrundlage
deshalb liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lassen Sie uns doch auch in der Debatte
darüber sprechen wie wir diese
Datengrundlage verbreitern können also
ist dafür beispielsweise ein
impfregister der richtige Weg das ist
ein wichtiger Punkt über den wir
sprechen müssen bei der Frage wie wir
die Datengrundlage verbessern können
müssen wir auch darüber sprechen wie
diese feinnahansierungen Abstimmung im
Rahmen der Impfpflicht ausgestaltet
werden können und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lassen sie uns nicht immer nur
alles schlecht reden denn zu dieser
Debatte gehört auch die positiven Dinge
anzusprechen wir tun ja immer so als
hätten wir im Rahmen der Debatte
insbesondere auch im Hinblick auf eine
Impfpflicht überhaupt nichts geschafft
und wenn wir auf die Zahlen schauen 84
Prozent der Erwachsenen sind
mittlerweile vollständig geimpft 90
Prozent der Senioren sind mittlerweile
geimpft und das sollten wir nicht
kleinreden aber wir sollten auch immer
darauf hinweisen dass impfen der Weg aus
der Krise ist und zum Thema
Datengrundlage liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Fallzahlen und Krankenhaus Inzidenz sind
als Indikatoren gut sie müssen aber
durch weitere Parameter ergänzt werden
wir brauchen einen fortlaufenden
Überblick über die Auslastung der
normalstationären Kapazitäten digital
regional differenziert dass die die
Register beispielsweise könnte da ein
gutes Vorbild sein wir müssen aber auch
präzise erfassen wo Arztpraxen an
Belastungsgrenzen geraten und genauso
wichtig ist der Überblick über die
Funktionsfähigkeit kritischer
Infrastrukturen deshalb liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir brauchen
ein präziseres Lagebild wir brauchen
aber auch in der Debatte mehr oder
weniger Aufgeregtheit wir müssen in der
Debatte immer genau begründen warum die
Notwendigkeit in einzelnen Bereichen für
eine Impfpflicht besteht denn Omegon das
sage ich wie viele andere auch ist zwar
eine dominante aber auch eine mildere
Variante und deshalb werden wir glaube
ich im Frühjahr einiges Althergebrachtes
überdenken müssen müssen und bei der
Frage ob wir dafür pauschale lö
Lösungen in den Blick nehmen eher auf
differenziertere setzen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
nach zwei Jahren Pandemie und
erheblichen grundrechtseingriffen denke
ich sollten wir auch hier im Parlament
im Rahmen der Debatte uns gegenseitig
zugestehen dass bei den Meinungen ein
breites Meinungsspektrum insbesondere im
Hinblick auf die impflischpflicht
herrscht ich hätte mir deshalb gewünscht
dass wir bei der Frage wie wir diese
Debatte führen im Vorfeld zumindest ein
Entwurf gehabt hätten den man im
parlamentarischen Verfahren hätte
diskutieren können
das ist das ist leider nicht passiert
jetzt kann man sagen das ist vergossene
Milch mein persönlicher Wunsch ist
allerdings dass wir auch bei diesen
ganzen Debatten dass unsere
Koordinatensystem nicht verloren geht
dafür was der Staat tun sollte und was
nicht auch das Prinzip der
Eigenverantwortung der Bürger
Zurückhaltung des Staates sollten wir
nicht vergessen und insofern glaube ich
werden wir letztendlich bei der Frage
der Kompromissfindung hier im Parlament
wie üblich auch einen Kompromiss finden
noch mal das beste Instrument aus der
Pandemie herauszukommen ist das Impfen
aber solange kein Instrument mit
absolutem Schutz zur Verfügung steht
wäre auch eine absolute Impfpflicht der
falsche Weg das dennoch geht es darum
dass wir als Union einen pragmatischen
Ansatz finden differenzieren statt
Aktionismus Pragmatismus statt Panik das
ist für die Akzeptanz unverzichtbar denn
eine Impfpflicht die wir vor Ort
umsetzen müssen und wollen wird nur dann
akzeptiert wenn Sie auch tatsächlich
umgesetzt und nachvollziehbar ist und
nicht zuletzt wir in der politischen
Kultur und in der gesellschaftlichen
Debatte die Tür zur Versöhnung offen
halten lassen wir uns das nicht
vergessen vielen Dank keine Sorge war
das der gesundheitspolitische Sprecher
der Unionsfraktion es gibt verschiedene
Wege hier im Bundestag zu einem Ergebnis
zu kommen ob man eine Impfpflicht eine
allgemeine möchte oder nicht es gibt
einmal den Weg über gruppenanträge und
ohne Fraktionszwang das möchte die
Ampelkoalition das möchte die
Bundesregierung die Unionsfraktion hatte
die ganze Zeit einen eigenen
Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung
verlangt auch keine Sorge jetzt noch mal
allerdings wurde im Vorfeld der Debatte
angekündigt dass die Union jetzt
vielleicht einen eigenen Gruppenantrag
vorlegen wird
setzt uns alle unter Druck Einsamkeit
seelische Belastungen nehmen zu Kinder
wollen endlich wieder unbeschwert lernen
und ihre Freundinnen treffen Künstlerin
warten darauf wieder aufzutreten und die
Menschen die Tag und Nacht unsere
Gesundheitsversorgung aufrecht erhalten
wollen endlich mal wieder Pause machen
uns eint liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
dass wir diese Pandemie endlich
überwinden wollen und impfen ist der Weg
aus der Pandemie impfen ist der
Schlüssel dafür die Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystems zu vermeiden damit
alle die medizinische und pflegerische
Hilfe brauchen Sie sicher bekommen und
dafür dafür brauchen wir eine deutliche
höhere Impfquote wir liegen im
europäischen Vergleich gerade mal im
Mittelfeld wäre die Impfkampagne
motivierender aufsuchender gewesen wie
im schönen Bundesland Bremen dann
müssten wir diese Debatte möglicherweise
gar nicht führen jetzt aber stehen wir
in der Verantwortung die bestehenden
Impflücken zu schließen
ich halte darum die Einführung einer
allgemeinen Impfpflicht ab 18 für
richtig
sich impfen lassen zu können ist
übrigens ein Privileg wer kann sollte es
auch tun der Bundesverband der
Organtransplantierten unterstützt die
Impfpflicht ab 18 auch sie sind auf
unsere Solidarität angewiesen
eine Impfpflicht bedeutet eine doppelte
Verpflichtung eine Verpflichtung der
BürgerInnen sich impfen zu lassen und
eine Verpflichtung des Staats jeder
Person ein geeignetes impfangebot zur
Verfügung zu stellen so gehen
Impfpflicht und impfrecht Hand in Hand
und wenn die Impfpflicht gelingen soll
dann heißt es nicht etwa weniger
Kommunikation sondern mehr
zielgruppenspezifische Aufklärung
mehrsprachig klar und verlässlich es
geht auch unter den Bedingungen einer
Impfpflicht immer um einen
ermöglichenden Staat das heißt für
Menschen die besondere Sorge haben wegen
der Spritze wegen der Impfung braucht es
über die ärztliche Aufklärung
hinausgehende Gesprächsangebote
macht es nun Sinn eine Impfpflicht auf
die über 50-Jährigen zu begrenzen ich
meine nein auch bei jüngeren Menschen
gibt es schwere Verläufe
longkowith ist ein zusätzliches Risiko
eine durchgemachte Infektion birgt nicht
nur für alle Altersgruppen hohe Risiken
sie schützt auch nicht so effektiv vor
weiteren Infektionen wie eine Impfung
und und das finde ich besonders relevant
wenn wir das Signal setzen würden impfen
ist vor allem für die über 50-Jährigen
wichtig birgt das sogar die Gefahr dass
die Impfbereitschaft bei den Jüngeren
abnimmt und das wäre kontraproduktiv
es gibt die Befürchtung dass eine
Impfpflicht zu mehr gesellschaftlicher
Spaltung führe ich gehe eher davon aus
dass eine klare und eindeutige
staatliche Regel die für alle
gleichermaßen gilt dabei hilft eine
gesellschaftliche Befriedung
herbeizuführen denn sie hilft auch
innere Ambivalenzen zu überwinden und
diese Chance sollten wir nutzen
je mehr Menschen in persönlichen Umfeld
geimpft sind desto höher ist auch die
eigene Impfbereitschaft es muss die
Regel werden geimpft zu sein und das
erreichen wir durch eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht lassen Sie uns gemeinsam
weiter im Austausch bleiben ich freue
mich auf die weiteren Beratungen vielen
Dank
Kirsten Kappert Gunther war das für
Bündnis 90 die grüne sie hat sich für
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht ab 18
ausgesprochen das entspricht dem Antrag
der gerade vorbereitet wird dem
Gruppenantrag von Dirk Wiese um Dirk
Wiese muss man sagen den
SPD-Abgeordneten und weitere Abgeordnete
die für eine Impfpflicht ab 18 werden
das Wetter der letzten Tage ist der
heutigen Debatte zur Impfpflicht
eigentlich angemessen es ist düster
bestellt um unser Land
als Abgeordnete dieses Hohen Hauses
setzen wir uns seit nunmehr als zwei
Jahren mit immer neuen Einschränkungen
und Verboten auseinander Werte Kollegen
wir alle erleben eine Zeit in der eine
deutsche Regierung wieder versucht ihre
autoritären Bestrebung durch das
Parlament zu bringen die programmierte
Einigkeit der Koalitionäre ist medial
gestützt über Differenzen wird kaum oder
überhaupt nicht mehr diskutiert es wird
viel mehr nur noch diffamiert es drängt
sich mir förmlich das Bild einer
Bundesregierung auf die sich wie ein
verwundetes Tier schon fast ängstlich
zurückzieht und aggressiv um sich beißt
sobald sich jemand versucht ihr
argumentativ zu nähern im Ergebnis gibt
es nur noch ein richtig oder falsch es
wird durchregiert doch mit welchen
Folgen muss man sich fragen wir sind an
einem Punkt angelangt an dem Impfstoffe
schon fast eine religiöse Stellung
erhalten sie sollen das verbindende
Element für alle Bürger sein damit sie
einen Teil der Gesellschaft sein dürfen
wenn ich glaubt und von seinem
Grundrecht auf Selbstbestimmung Gebrauch
macht ist automatisch ausgeschlossen
beispiele hierfür erleben Sie alle
tagtäglich liebe Kollegen
einmalig jedoch ist das erstmals
Parlamentarier ihre Aufgaben nicht mehr
uneingeschränkt wahrnehmen können zwei
Beispiele kurz angeführt aus meiner
Fraktion wurde dem Kollegen Joachim
Wunder die Teilnahme an einer
Ausschusssitzung verwehrt
eine weitaus größere tragwerte werden
wir allerdings morgen erleben erstmals
erstmals werden nicht alle Mitglieder
des Deutschen Bundestages an der
Gedenkveranstaltung des 27 Januar
teilnehmen dürfen und der Grund in
beiden Fällen ein falscher sogenannter
fehlender Status die Begründung sind
vielfältig jedoch weder politisch
rechtlich noch medizinisch
nachvollziehbar und ich wiederhole das
noch mal eindrücklich ein nicht
geimpfter Parlamentarier gesund
getestet darf morgen nicht im Bundestag
betreten und vielmehr ist genau das und
ich zitiere Armin Laschet von gestern
Abend genau das ist eine Schande was
hier passiert
nicht die Kandidatur für das Amt des
Bundespräsidenten gilt es zu verurteilen
sondern die Art mit der die Regierenden
versuchen ihren Willen durchzusetzen und
die Arroganz diesen nicht einmal mehr
zur Diskussion zu stellen der Umgang mit
unserem Grundgesetz wird immer
schamloser nachträglich wird der Status
genesen durch eine staatliche
Institution aberkannt Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister brauchen wir
eigentlich ihr Ministerium noch oder
übernimmt das zukünftig komplett das RKI
falls ja da können wir die freien Mittel
in meine sächsische Heimatregion
investieren durch ihre vorzeitige
Energiewende samt der Industrialisierung
können wir dort jeden Euro dringend
gebrauchen meine Damen und Herren
diese politischen Schachzüge sind im
höchsten Maß zu verurteilen unsere
etablierten Strukturen werden ebenso
nachhaltig Gespräch geschwächt wie die
Stellung des Parlaments und genau das
ist die Demokratie gefährdet von der sie
ja sonst immer so gerne reden wer der
Bundesregierung geht es ihnen eigentlich
noch um unser Land oder um dem bloßen
Beweis wer eigentlich die Machthaber
sind und gegen
und gegen einige die mit der Moralkeule
durch unser Gesellschaft gehen wird nun
auch wegen Untreue ermittelt dass ein
schwerwiegender Tatbestand meine Damen
und Herren und viel schlimmer Frau
Berber und herabick sie sind
Bundesminister ihres Kabinetts herr
Scholz wie glaubwürdig meinen sie
eigentlich sind diese Personalien für
unsere Bürger überhaupt noch
sie sind ganz offensichtlich einen
schwarz-weiß Denk- und Handlungsschema
über viele politikwälder hinweggefangen
sie haben vollkommen den Blick für ihre
eigentliche Aufgabe verloren eine Vision
für die Zukunft
eine Vision für die Zukunft unseres
Landes zu erzeugen die gibt es
schlichtweg nicht wir möchten Sie dass
Deutschland in 30 oder 70 Jahren
aussieht wie sieht eigentlich überhaupt
ihre corona-exit-strategie aus sie ist
schlichtweg nicht vorhanden herr Scholz
alles Szenarien die Sie unseren Bürgern
skizzieren zeigen dass wir mit immer
mehr Einschränkungen leben lernen müssen
das ganze mit erneuerbaren Energien
einen immer stärker werdenden Staat und
voll digitalisiert natürlich wie man
davon jedoch seine Miete bezahlen soll
oder die Stromrechnung bezahlen soll
daran hat niemand gedacht dass ihnen
auch scheinbar völlig egal welche
Bundesregierung
geben Sie den Bürgern endlich Antworten
zu den Wirkungen und auch Nebenwirkungen
der Impfung deren Wirksamkeit und
Sicherheit werfen viele Fragen auf
schaffen sie endlich ein verlässliches
und vor allem vertrauensvolles Klima
eine impfliche jedenfalls lehnen wir
sowohl für einzelne Berufsgruppen als
auch allgemein vollständig ab
die Alternative für Deutschland steht
für Freiheit statt Spaltung vielen Dank
war das der Fraktionschef der
afd-fraktion die AFD lehnt jegliche
Impfpflicht ab das hat er noch mal
unterstrichen die afd-fraktion hat
übrigens auch in der vergangenen Woche
vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht Klage
gegen die neuen corona-regeln im
Bundestag eingericht gegen die neuen
zwei g plus Regeln im Bundestag
frau Präsidentin meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen gestalten Sie
mir eine Bemerkung vorneweg
wenn man merken wollte dass die AFD zur
Sache nichts beizutragen hat dann hat
man das jetzt gesehen weil außer wüste
Beschimpfung zu allen möglichen Dingen
und das Fehlen zu sachlichen Argumenten
zu der Debatte heute hat ihre Rede
nichts anderes gezeigt der Europa
wer möchte zweitens mich bedanken ich
möchte mich bei denen als Abgeordneter
bei den Fraktionen bedanken dass Sie
dieses debattenformat hier möglich
gemacht haben denn es ist der Sache
angemessen es ist auch dem Parlament
angemessen denn wir merken ja überall in
den Freundeskreisen auch in den
Ortsvereinen der Parteien in den Milieus
in den Vereinen überall wird über diese
Sache auch sehr leidenschaftlich zum
Teil auch sehr hitzig debattiert und da
gelten auch manch alte Regeln nicht und
deshalb ist es richtig und gut dass
dieses Verfahren dafür sorgt dass jede
Kollegin und jeder Kollege absolut frei
von allen Sorgen seine Bedenken seine
Argumente hier vortragen kann und das
zeigt dass das Gegenteil von dem
richtiges heropaler was sie behauptet
haben es gilt eben nicht die Logik der
Macht sondern es gilt die Logik des
Arguments und des Freigesprochenen
Wortes liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wer aus einer schwierigen Frage der
Ethik eine parteitaktische Frage der
Macht machen möchte beweist dass er oder
sie die Dimension der Frage nicht
verstanden hat
ich möchte ein paar Anmerkungen aus
rechtlicher Sicht machen wohlgemerkt
nicht in amtlicher Eigenschaft sondern
weil ich das Recht zu meinem Beruf
gemacht habe und seit ich hier im
Parlament tätig bin auch immer mich um
Fragen des Rechts gekümmert habe und ich
höre immer wieder wenn es um die Frage
der Impfpflicht gehe dass da könne das
Verfassungsrecht in Wahrheit keinen
Beitrag zu leisten denn Karlsruhe habe
doch dem Gesetzgeber eine kart-lounge
gegeben und diese Missverständnis möchte
ich hier entgegentreten was Karlsruhe in
der
bundesnotbremsen Entscheidung gesagt hat
war dass diese Frage so komplex so
schwierig auch mit so vielen
prognostischen Elementen also
letztendlich Spekulationen auf die
Zukunft versehen ist das Richter ihre
Beurteilung nicht an die Stelle des
Gesetzgebers setzen können das heißt
aber nicht dass wir frei sind sondern
dass wir umso sorgfältiger über diese
ein paar geringen müssen weil nach uns
keine andere Instanz in der Frage im
Ergebnis vermutlich mehr kommen wird und
auch deshalb ist dieses Verfahren der
Sache angemessen meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und der Beitrag des Verfassungsrechts zu
dieser Debatte ist neben den
medizinischen und ethischen Fragen enorm
denn unsere Verfassung verlangt von uns
dass wir das Ziel klar benennen da
reicht es nicht von einer Botschaft an
die geimpften oder ungeimpften zu reden
dass die einen guten oder die anderen
die schlechten Bürger sein da reicht es
auch nicht zu sagen dass es doch klug
wäre wenn ein Mensch mit einer Diabetes
sich doch besser impfen lassen wollte
denn wenn es lediglich um den
medizinischen Eigenschutz geht reicht
das nicht aus das wäre Paternalismus das
wird man im Lande Immanuel Kants noch
sagen dürfen
sondern worum es gehen muss ist der
Schutz des öffentlichen
Gesundheitssystems die Verteidigung der
Intensivstation und auch der
Normalstation vor Überlastung und darum
muss es gehen
und deshalb müssen wir uns die Frage
stellen und zwar ernsthaft ist das auch
mit milderen Mitteln möglich und deshalb
ist meine Bitte dass wir uns zwei Fragen
wirklich sehr ernsthaft vornehmen
wenn der Expertenrat der
corona-expertenrat sagt dass
insbesondere die Gruppe der über
50-Jährigen ungeimpften die größte Sorge
bereitet bei der Frage einer künftigen
Überlastung der Intensivstation müssen
wir die mildere alternative einer
altersbezogenen einer gestuften
Impfpflicht sehr ernst nehmen aber auch
die Anhänger dieser gestuften
Impfpflicht müssen sich ernsthaft die
Frage stellen ist es nicht denkbar dass
wir mit den sehr vielversprechenden
antiviralen Medikamenten die in den
Studien eine extrem hohe Wirksamkeit
zeigen wenn wir die schnell und
flächendeckend zur Verfügung stellen ist
nicht möglicherweise auch das eine
Perspektive und ein Beitrag um unsere
Intensivstation und unsere Krankenhäuser
vor Überlastung zu schützen ich traue
mir heute da noch keine abschließende
Meinung zu aber wir müssen diese
milderen Alternativen nach besten Wissen
und Gewissen prüfen und darum möchte ich
bitten in dieser Debatte herzlichen Dank
meine Damen und Herren Marco Buschmann
war das von der FDP der nicht als
Bundesjustizminister hier sprechen
wollte sondern als Abgeordneter und
deswegen auch in die Abgeordneten rein
sich wieder hinsetzen nicht auf die
Regierungsbank also er wird zumindest
auch noch mal dafür den Expertenrat
anzuhören und zu bedenken ob man eine
altersbezogene Impfpflicht in Erwägung
zieht Kathrin Vogler jetzt für die Linke
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen seit zwei Jahren leiden die
Menschen in diesem Land unter der
corona-pandemie und auch unter den
Maßnahmen die ergriffen werden müssen um
dafür zu sorgen dass erkrankte schwer
erkrankte noch in den Krankenhäusern
behandelt werden können
diese Maßnahmen ob kontaktbeschränkungen
3g-2g oder quarantäneanordnungen greifen
tief in die persönliche Freiheit ein und
angesichts der hoch ansteckenden
omicronvariante befürchten wir jetzt
sogar dass beispielsweise die Versorgung
mit Strom und Wasser zusammenbrechen
könnte das ist gemeint wenn wir
PolitikerInnen von kritischen
Infrastrukturen reden
die Beschäftigten in den Krankenhäusern
die ja schon vor der Pandemie am Limit
waren riskieren heute täglich Leben und
Gesundheit um Leid zu vermindern und
Leben zu retten und selbst wenn in
unserem Gesundheitswesen vor Corona
alles in Ordnung gewesen wäre selbst
dann wäre eine durchseuchungsstrategie
vollkommen unethisch denn der Staat ist
verpflichtet das Recht auf Leben und
körperliche Unversehrtheit aller
Menschen zu schützen auch der Kranken
der schwachen und der alten
was wir erleben in der Gesellschaft ist
eine zum Teil völlig verzerrte
Risikowahrnehmung die Gefahr durch
kurvit 19 schwer zu erkranken dauerhafte
Gesundheitsschäden zu erleiden oder
sogar zu sterben wird massiv
unterschätzt stattdessen fürchten sich
noch viel zu viele vor den sehr sicheren
und inzwischen milliardenfach erprobten
Impfstoffen die einen schweren Verlauf
mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit verhindern
können und das kann ich ihnen von der
cdu/csu und von der SPD leider nicht
ersparen auch ihre Politik der letzten
zwei Jahre hat zu dieser Verunsicherung
beigetragen immer wieder haben sie Dinge
versprochen die sich dann in der
Realität nicht halten ließ
und immer wieder haben sie Warnungen aus
der Wissenschaft und aus anderen und
Erfahrungen aus anderen Ländern
ignoriert und mussten hinterher
nachsteuern eine vorausschauende Politik
war das nie und das merken wir zum
Beispiel auch an den immer noch
fehlenden Luftfiltern in Schulen und an
den viel zu wenigen testkapazitäten und
bis heute
bis heute hat es die Bundesregierung
nicht geschafft die Bevölkerung über den
Nutzen der Impfungen so aufzuklären dass
die corona-leugner die das Internet mit
Desinformation Fluten gegen eine Wand
der Solidarität laufen ja der
Solidarität das ist ein viel
missbrauchtes Wort aber ohne Solidarität
werden wir den Weg aus dieser Krise
nicht finden
eine Impfpflicht die ein Eingriff in die
körperliche selbstbestimmung ist kann da
immer nur ultima ratio sein also eine
letzte Möglichkeit wenn anders der
Schutz der Gesundheit und die
Wiedererlangung der Freiheiten nicht
erreicht werden können
aber dann davon bin ich überzeugt kann
eine Impfpflicht nicht nur
verfassungsgemäß sondern unter Umständen
sogar zwingend geboten sein um andere
hohe Rechtsgüter zu schützen das Recht
auf Leben und körperliche unversehrt hat
die persönlichen Freiheiten und die
Funktionsfähigkeit von
Bildungseinrichtungen Gesundheitswesen
und öffentlicher Daseinsvorsorge und das
müssen wir wirklich sehr sorgsam
besprechen also ich sehe da noch nicht
dass wir da am Ende der Diskussion sind
die Voraussetzung wäre es aber auch dem
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern eine
solche Pflicht so leicht wie möglich zu
machen und da brauchen wir
niedrigschwellige impfangebote aktive
Einladung verständliche
zielgruppengerechte Informationen wie
das Unsere Gesundheitssenatorin in
Bremen wirklich vorbildlich gemacht hat
und
sie entbindet die Politik nicht von der
Verantwortung unser Gesundheitswesen so
zu gestalten dass die dort arbeitende
nicht täglich über Limit gehen müssen
vor während oder nach einer Pandemie und
Herr Scholz und Herr Lauterbach da
müssen sie ihn liefern
Katrin Vogler war das für die Linke eine
Impfpflicht als ultima ratio hat sie
gesagt also als letztes Mittel wenn
alles andere nicht funktioniert die
Linke hat es sich so von Meinungsbild
Ende November für eine Impfpflicht für
Erwachsene ausgesprochen aber angesichts
der Variante um mikronen äußerten sich
Vertreter der Linken auch inzwischen
wieder zurückhaltender
der Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen es gibt nur einen einzigen
Gegner in dieser Pandemie und das ist
das Virus ich bin froh dass die
allermeisten in diesem Haus und in
unserem Land sich darin einig sind und
ich bin froh dass wir jetzt diese
intensive Debatte über den richtigen Weg
führen wie wir die Pandemie endlich
überwinden können in den letzten Jahren
haben wir uns sehr bemüht jeweils
situationsangepasst und maßvoll zu
reagieren wir sind dabei zumeist mit
weniger harten Einschränkungen als in
den allermeisten Ländern ausgekommen und
trotzdem sind viele Maßnahmen auch bei
uns mit erheblichen Belastungen
Folgeschäden und Problemen verbunden mir
geht es heute darum dafür zu werben dass
wir angesichts einer ungewissen Zukunft
konsequent für einen der bewussten
Vorsorge uns entscheiden
aber wie kann Vorsorge gelingen in einer
Zeit in der sich der Wissensstand von
Tag zu Tag erweitert und wir regelmäßig
hinzu lernen bei aller Unsicherheit und
Ungenauigkeit der Vorhersage haben wir
immerhin die Gewissheit das Impfen
schützt aber wir haben eben auch gelernt
allein auf die Hoffnung zu setzen dass
die aktuelle Welle die letzte sein Wort
ist keine gute Option erinnern wir uns
an den ersten pandemie-herbst erinnern
wir uns an den zweiten immer wieder
waren wir ausreichend nicht ausreichend
vorbereitet immer wieder wurde Politik
das Versäumnis guter Vorsorge
vorgeworfen und einen dritten
unkontrollierten pandemie-herbst darf es
nicht geben
weil die Zeit läuft und das Virus keine
Rücksicht nimmt auf Unentschlossenheit
Skepsis oder gar trotz
darum plädiere ich heute für die
Einführung einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht
für alle Erwachsenen beschränkt auf das
sarskow zwei Virus zeitlich befristet
und auf drei Impfdosen begrenzt mit
freier impfstoffwahl und
selbstverständlich muss es medizinische
Ausnahmen geben
ja wir hoffen alle darauf dass wir nach
der unicronwelle rasch zurückkehrenden
einen unbeschwerten Alltag ohne
freiheitseinschränkungen aber kein
Experte kann uns heute sagen dass die
Pandemie mit Omicron weitgehend
überstanden sein wird keiner gibt uns
die Sicherheit nicht von weiteren
Virusvarianten überrascht zu werden
diese Ungewissheit darf aber eben nicht
zutatenlosigkeit führen wir können
vorsorgen und damit vor die nächste
Welle kommen dafür braucht es jetzt eine
mutige Weichenstellung und die wollen
wir vornehmen
von Politik wird in dieser Zeit zu Recht
Orientierung erwartet und diese müssen
wir mit klaren Botschaften geben wir
werden die Lasten der Pandemie Folgen
gerechter verteilen und dürfen nicht
weiter die immer gleichen belasten das
sind vor allem die Kinder und
Jugendlichen die selbst am wenigsten
gefährdet und dennoch am meisten
eingeschränkt waren und es sind die
Beschäftigten in der Pflege die für uns
unverzichtbare Arbeit leisten und seit
Beginn der Pandemie besonderer
Gefährdung und Belastung ausgesetzt sind
und die sich jetzt durch die notwendige
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht noch
mehr als ewige und alleinige
Lastenträger fühlen eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht ab 18 sendet die klare
Botschaft wir alle stehen in der
Verantwortung füreinander gesunde für
kranke Erwachsene für Kinder junge für
alte wir alle gemeinsam stehen in der
Verantwortung für Energie die in unseren
Krankenhäusern und pflegereinrichtungen
ungemein belastet sind
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam den Gegner
bezwingen der uns alle der unser aller
Gesundheit bedroht man verweist auf
öffentlich zugängliche Quellen und nimmt
nicht mehr ansatzweise eine eigene
Einordnung vor keine Positionierung zum
Thema Impfpflicht keine Antwort auf die
Frage von Vollzug und Kontrolle keine
Antwort auf die Frage eines
impfregisters das sind nur einige
Beispiele stattdessen verweist man auf
das Parlament und die gruppenanträge und
die angekündigte Hilfestellung für das
Parlament die können wir hier nicht
sehen was wir aber erleben das ist
Arbeitsverweigerung der Bundesregierung
und eine Missachtung der Opposition
und für uns ist ganz klar die
Bundesregierung ist nach wie vor in der
Pflicht ein praktikablen und
verfassungskonform Vorschlag vorzulegen
der zentrale Fragen beantwortet und die
Expertise der Ministerien einbringt
wie bewerten aber wir diese ernste Lage
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht hilft uns
kurzfristig in der aktuell dramatischen
Situation nicht weiter dafür liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel ist
viel zu viel Zeit ungenutzt verstrichen
aktuell bräuchte es vor allem mehr
freiwillig Impfungen und es bräuchte
eine erfolgreiche Impfkampagne aber die
Impfkampagne für die Buße und
erstimpfungen stockt das von
Bundeskanzler Scholz ausgegebene Ziel
von 80 Prozent erstimpfungen bis Ende
Januar wird leider ganz klar verfehlt
die Quote bei den boosterimpfungen
stagniert bei 50 Prozent und auch das
ausgegebene Ziel zwischen Weihnachten
und Ende Januar 30 Millionen Impfungen
zu schaffen wird ganz klar nicht
erreicht wir liegen stand heute bei
knapp 15 Millionen Impfungen
das ist bedauerlich und das zeigt uns
eins der Bundesgesundheitsminister ist
mit seiner Impfkampagne hier ganz klar
gefordert
aus meiner Sicht steht aber auch fest
wir müssen uns für den Ernstfall
weiterer möglicherweise
gefährlicher Virusvarianten im Herbst
Wappen denn wir wünschen uns dass alle
nicht aber es kann eben auch niemand
ausschließen und eine vollständige oder
teilweise Impfpflicht sie kann die
Voraussetzung sein ab einem bestimmten
Zeitpunkt sie kann notwendig sein um
eine Überforderung unseres
Gesundheitssystems zu verhindern und den
individualschutz zu erhöhen
das ist aber eine Frage von Daten Fakten
Fragen von Verhältnismäßigkeit und
Umsetzbarkeit und das ist eine Frage das
sind Fragen die hat die Regierung zu
beantworten und die Entscheidung darüber
die trifft das Parlament das ist eine
politische Entscheidung
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen fest
steht auch ganz klar wir brauchen ein
impfregister Fachleute aus dem
medizinischen aus dem ethischen und aus
dem rechtlichen Bereich sie raten
dringend dazu für diese Krise aber auch
für künftige pandemie-krisen ein solches
Register einzurichten denn es wäre mehr
als hilfreich wenn eine zuverlässige und
sichere Datengrundlage über den
Impfstatus unserer Bevölkerung Auskunft
gibt ein Register kann uns helfen bei
der Ansprache und Informationen es kann
bei der Datenerhebung und Auswertung
helfen diese zu verbessern es kann
Vorhersagen über die zu erwartende
Belastung unseres Gesundheitssystems
treffen und damit auch eine bessere
Bewertung von nötigen oder nicht nötigen
Maßnahmen ermöglichen denn am Ende ist
eins klar eine bessere Datengrundlage
das ist das was man braucht es ist nicht
ein mehr anbel sondern es schützt gerade
auch unser aller Freiheitsrechte und
deshalb fordern wir die Bundesregierung
auch auf die Einrichtung eines
allgemeinen impfregisters unverzüglich
auf den Weg zu bringen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren in der
Regierung ich kann es ihnen nicht
ersparen packen sie endlich an wir
brauchen Klartext und Klarheit bei
Impfkampagne Impfpflicht und
impfregister und es gibt verdammt viel
zu tun Dankeschön Andrea Lindholz war
das für die CDU CSU-Fraktion hier
wiederum die Kritik der Union das ist
kein eigenen Regierungsentwurf gäbe und
ein impfregister sein nötig sei er sagt
Andrea Lindholz der Entwurf der
Gruppenantrag der in Vorbereitung ist ja
sich für eine Impfpflicht ab 18 Jahren
ausspricht um den SPD-Abgeordneten Dirk
Wiese der sieht kein impfregister vor
der Grund einen allzu großer Zeit
Aufwand außerdem gibt es auch Bedenken
von Datenschützern nächste Rednerin hier
Paula pichota für die Grünen sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe Damen und
Herren sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und vor
allen Dingen auch liebe Frau Lindholz
ich möchte sie nicht auffordern ich
möchte sie einfach als Ärztin bitten
daran zu denken das System und Debatten
in diesem Haus gibt die wichtiger sind
als parteipolitische Profilierung darum
bitte ich Sie und es tut mir auch leid
dass ich damit jetzt hier so anfangen
muss
das Spannende an dieser Debatte ist doch
egal wer von uns die in den letzten
Wochen geführt hat in diesem Haus und
außerhalb dieses Hauses es geht fast
niemand in diese Debatte ohne seinen
ganz persönlichen Rucksack an Emotionen
an Perspektiven auch an Dingen die ihn
persönlich wundgescheuert haben in den
letzten 24 Monaten in dieser Debatte und
das anzuerkennen dass vor allen Dingen
auch diese verschiedenen Perspektiven
mit darüber entscheiden werden was am
Ende hier mehrheitsfähig ist das gehört
doch an der Stelle zu einer ehrlichen
Debatte dazu und wenn wir uns da
anschauen
und wenn wir uns da anschauen wie
unterschiedlich diese Perspektiven sind
heute wird zum Beispiel Herr Kubicki
hier gleich noch reden wo ich gerade das
Vergnügen hatte neben ihm zu sitzen das
ist eine ganz andere Perspektive als
meine aus Schleswig-Holstein mit dieser
vergleichsweise guten Impfquote im
Bundesland was immer ziemlich gut durch
die Pandemie gekommen ist da verstehe
ich dass man zu der Überzeugung kommen
kann dass es keine Impfpflicht braucht
aber dann muss man sich auch die andere
Perspektive anhören und die kommt in
meiner Person aus Sachsen sie wissen
dass unser Bundesland hat die mit
Abstand schlechteste Impfquote wir sind
mit unseren knapp über 60 Prozent sind
wir näher an der tschechischen Impfquote
als am bundesdeutschen Durchschnitt wir
haben die meisten pro kopftoten kurz vor
sachsen-anhaltung Thüringen und vor
allen Dingen ist es auch so dass er
diese niedrige Impfquote auch dazu
geführt hat dass wir in den letzten
Monaten besonders langwierige und
besonders tiefgreifende Maßnahmen auch
noch mal bei uns hatten und das muss mit
berücksichtigt werden ich will nicht
dass wir am Ende eine Debatte haben wie
berücksichtigen wir vor allem die
Bundesländer die gerade die schlechteste
Impfquote haben aber wir brauchen am
Ende dieses Prozess ist eine Regelung
die für alle Bundesländer funktioniert
und hier sind schon Punkte angesprochen
worden
die vor allen Dingen auch die
Umsetzbarkeit betreffen und ich möchte
einfach darauf hinweisen dass es einen
großen Unterschied macht auch wie
praktikabelnde Regelung ist ob ich in
dem Bundesland noch 40 Prozent
ungeimpfte habe oder nur 20 Prozent ich
spreche heute als eine Vertreterin von
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen in diesem
Haus die vorschlagen einen sogenannten
Mittelweg zu gehen obwohl ich mit dem
Begriff nicht ganz ganz glücklich bin
und dieser Mittelweg heißt wir machen
eine Verpflichtung zur Impfung ab 50 für
die besonders gefährdeten Gruppen wir
machen aber auch eine verpflichtende
Impfberatung ab 18 und es fällt mir
natürlich auch nicht leicht da zu sagen
das ist der beste Weg durch diese Krise
und aus dieser Krise ist
aber es ist auf jeden Fall so dass wir
hier versuchen die gesellschaftlichen
Nebenwirkungen die dieses Medikament
Impfpflicht auch haben kann mitzudenken
und die zu minimieren niemand kann Ihnen
sagen und das kann ich jetzt nur noch
anreißen niemand kann Ihnen sagen ob wir
tatsächlich diesen befriedenen Effekt in
allen Bundesländern haben werden oder ob
es nicht auch radikalisierungstendenzen
geben wird und da reicht auch kein
Glaube als Mensch der in Sachsen lebt
kann ich da nicht drauf vertrauen dass
es einfach Befriedung geben wird da muss
ich mit einpreisen dass es auch anders
sein kann und deswegen werde ich für
diesen anderen Weg und ich freue mich
auf die nächsten Wochen mit ihnen weil
das Schöne an dieser Debatte ist am Ende
ja auch das ist fast alle von uns eint
dass wir diese Zumutung diese
demokratische und gesundheitliche und
soziale Zumutung die diese Pandemie ist
dass wir die endlich hinter uns bringen
und wir tragen fast alle in diesem Haus
Verantwortung egal ob hier oder in den
Ländern und deswegen freue ich mich auf
die Zusammenarbeit mit Ihnen vielen Dank
und dieser Mittelweg der könnte so
aussehen wie der Antrag der gerade
erarbeitet wird von einer Gruppe
Abgeordneter um den
FDP-Abgeordneten anschuh Ullmann
wiederum aber wie gesagt Sie haben es ja
gehört es haben sich auch andere aus
anderen Fraktionen deswegen ja
fraktionsoffen und Gruppenantrag schon
angeschlossen also die eine Impfpflicht
ab 50 vorsehen allerdings als ersten
Schritt sollen sich alle ungeimpften
verpflichtend beraten lassen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Werte
Damen und Herren unser Land steht an der
Schwelle eines beispiellosen Sündenfalls
die Absicht eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
gegen das Coronavirus einzuführen ist
ein Anschlag auf die Freiheit und
Menschenwürde und auf Grundrecht auf die
körperliche Unversehrtheit
die Impfpflicht ist ein autoritärer
Amoklauf gegen die Grundfesten unserer
demokratischen und rechtsstaatlichen
Grundordnung wenn der Staat sich anmaß
über die Körper seiner Bürger zu
entscheiden ist das ein elementarer
Zivilisationsbruch
es ist ein Trauerspiel das wir überhaupt
darüber reden müssen für eine
corona-impfpflicht egal ob für alle oder
für einzelne Bevölkerungsgruppen gibt es
keine Rechtfertigung weder medizinisch
noch ethisch noch juristisch eine
Impfpflicht gegen eine Krankheit die für
mehr als 99 Prozent der Menschen keine
lebensgefährliche Bedrohung darstellt
mit einem Impfstoff der weder vor
Ansteckung noch vor der Weitergabe des
Erregers zuverlässig schützt ist absurd
Menschen zu einer Impfung zu nötigen und
zu zwingen ist deshalb eine unerhörte
Grenzüberschreitung die Impfpflicht ist
verfassungswidrig und unverhältnismäßig
es gibt andere
es gibt andere vernünftige und
zielführende Wege um die
Gesundheitsversorgung aufrecht zu
erhalten zum Beispiel indem die
Gesundheitsminister ihren Job machen im
Bund und in den Ländern
für anständige Arbeitsbedingungen sorgen
ordentliche Bezahlung und mehr Personal
in den Kliniken die Impfpflicht ist auch
nicht durchführbar davor waren die
Kassenärzte da verwarnt der Beamtenbund
davor warnt der Arbeitgeberverband
Gesamtmetall wie wollen sie eigentlich
Millionen von Bürger die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen zu einer Impfung
zwingen mit Bußgeldern und
Erzwingungshaft wie stellen Sie sich das
vor
und darum unser Rat an sie hören Sie
also nicht nur auf die Pharma-Lobbyisten
sondern hören Sie auf die Praktika in
diesem Land
aber sie wissen ja eben auch dass die
Impfpflicht der Impfzwang falsch ist vor
der Wahl haben sie selbst noch ganz
anders geredet herr Scholz und Herr
Lindner die Impfpflicht ist nicht
zuletzt vor allem eins ein gigantischer
Wählerbetrug ein skandalöser
Vertrauensbruch darüber reden wir
sie klammern sich an die Impfpflicht
weil sie sich komplett verrannt haben
verrannt in eine Politik der
Bevormundung und Entrechtung zwei Jahre
regide corona-politik gebaut auf
falschen Zahlen manipulierten
Statistiken widersprüchlichen Behauptung
haben ihre Glaubwürdigkeit gründlich
ramponiert sie haben das Land mit
lebenden Regelwerken und einer
kafkaisten Corona Bürokratie überzogen
die die Bürger in die Verzweiflung
treiben ihr Versuch einen defacto
Impfzwang über sinnlose und willkürliche
2G und 3g-regeln einzuführen hat die
Gesellschaft bereits tief gespalten vor
allem Kinder und Jugendliche leiden
unter der Zerstörung ihres sozialen
Umfeldes
denn diese Regelwerke ihnen aufzwingen
diese Quälerei muss ein Ende haben sie
haben eine Behörde das
Robert-Koch-Institut dazu ermächtigt mit
einseitigen Änderungen dieser Regel
Millionen Menschen über Nacht und nach
Belieben in ihren Rechten weiter zu
beschneiden das ausgerechnet im
Bundestag
willkürentscheidung wie die
Einschränkung des genesenen Status nur
abgeschwächt gelten sollen empfinden die
Bürger zu Recht als Hohn
alle Menschen sind gleich manche
gleicher damit haben sie im übrigen
völlig unbeabsichtigt offenbart was sie
wirklich von den Menschen da draußen
halten und bereits jetzt ist abzusehen
dass die von ihnen durchgedrückte
Impfpflicht für die Medizin und
Pflegebereich
Existenzen ruiniert
engagierte Fachkräfte mit Berufsverbot
belegt und die Krise in diesem Sektor
noch verschärft kommen Sie also heraus
aus ihrer Bunkermentalität machen Sie
das Fenster auf schauen Sie nach Europa
was hier passiert in England fallen nach
und nach alle corona-restriktionen nicht
trotz sondern wegen ormicon das gleiche
in Dänemark in Spanien will man das
Virus künftig nur noch wie eine normale
Grippe behandeln
in Tschechien wird die geplante
Impfpflicht für ältere und bestimmte
Berufsgruppen wieder einkassiert sie hat
sich nämlich als Flop erwiesen und hören
Sie auf die Bürger zu verunglimpfen den
dieser großen Protestbewegungen in der
Geschichte unseres Landes ihre Stimme
äußern nehmen Sie diese Stimmen ernst
und schaffen sie endlich diese
unsinnigen und diskriminierenden Regeln
ab und zwar vollständig und überall
bittern verurteilte im Pflicht für
Krankenhäuser und Pflegeeinrichtungen
kippen Sie sie bevor es zu spät ist
darum bitten wir Sie wir müssen mit dem
Virus Leben Freiheit und
Eigenverantwortung sind der Schlüssel
jeder muss für sich frei entscheiden
können ob er sich durch eine Impfung und
auf eine andere Art und Weise schützen
möchte darum lassen sie um Gottes Willen
die Hände von der Impfpflicht ich
bedanke mich
alles beide war dass die
Fraktionsvorsitzende der afd-fraktion ja
ab Mitte März gilt eine
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht für
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer in
Kliniken in Tageskliniken in Pflegeheim
in Arzt und Zahnarztpraxen bei rettungs-
und Pflegediensten auch ins
Geburtshäusern beispielsweise begründet
wird das damit das Mitarbeiter in diesen
Einrichtungen eben engen Kontakt zu
besonders gefährdeten Personen haben das
ist bereits beschlossene Sache Wolfgang
Kubicki jetzt der sich in einem
Gruppenantrag gegen eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht ausgesprochen hat
Haus bedanken dafür dass wir trotz
unterschiedlicher Auffassung im Ergebnis
eine sehr respektvolle und sehr faire
Debatte haben führen können denn wir
alle wissen dass wir eigentlich nichts
wissen trotzdem unsere Bewertung
vornehmen müssen anhand der Datenlage
die wir haben und die kann naturgemäß
unterschiedlich ausfallen
und da ich
die weiteres Kollegen Sorge sehr
aufmerksam zugehört hat ist mir klar
geworden dass die orientierungsdebatte
wirklich einen Sinn hat denn die Union
sucht ja noch eine Orientierung und wir
sind dabei Ihnen dabei zu helfen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meinen
persönlichen meine persönlichen
freed-days waren die Tage meiner
corona-impfungen ich habe mich bewusst
für die Impfung und fürs Boostern
entschieden weil ich der festen
Überzeugung war und bin dass es mich mit
großer Wahrscheinlichkeit vor einem
schweren Krankheitsverlauf und vor dem
Tod durch Corona bewahrt es war für mich
persönlich ein enorm befreiendes Gefühl
es ist ein großes Geschenk dass dieser
Impfstoff innerhalb so kurzer Zeit
entwickelt wurde und dass ich mich
außerdem frei entscheiden konnte diesen
Schritt zu gehen ich bin froh und
dankbar in einem Gemeinwesen leben zu
können indem das möglich ist
reden wir heute über die Impfpflicht
müssen wir gleichzeitig darüber sprechen
wie der Staat diejenigen gegenübertritt
die sich bisher gegen eine Impfung
entschieden haben ich erinnere
ausdrücklich daran dass es noch nicht
allzu lange her ist das ist der
ausdrückliche Wille der überwältigen
Mehrheit dieses Hauses war den Bürgern
und Bürgern selbst die Freiheit zu
Entscheidung zu überlassen der Gedanke
war grundlegend dass der staatliche
Eingriff auf einen bestimmten Zeitpunkt
enden muss wenn alle ein impfangebot
erhalten haben und an jeder das
individuelle Lebensrisiko wieder selbst
trägt
setzt die Mehrheit des Hohen Hauses nun
aber trotz aller Betäubungen zuvor die
allgemeine Impfpflicht um hat das
Auswirkungen auf das Menschenbild dass
dieses Gemeinwesen aussendet so mag der
Tag der Impfung für all jene die sich
freiwillig hier zu entscheiden der
Freedom Day gewesen sein wir haben die
Ihnen den Tag nennen an dem sie gegen
ihren erklärten Willen geimpft wurden
die Kollegen ist es häufig zu hören dass
eine Impfung vernünftig ist und deshalb
die staatliche Verpflichtung ein Gebot
der gesellschaftlichen Notwendigkeit sei
ich teile ausdrücklich die Auffassung
dass eine Impfung vernünftig ist
trotzdem halte ich die Idee der
staatliche für alle Bürgerinnen und
Bürger fest was vernünftig ist zumindest
für problematisch
die innenwellen Gründe jene Wellen
Gründe sich nicht impfen zu lassen
können vielfältig sein wir machen es uns
viel zu einfach wenn wir erklären
hauptsächlich corona-leugner und
rechtsradikale entschieden sich gegen
die Impfung das ist mitnichten so wir
müssen respektieren das ist durchaus
bedenkenswerte psychologische oder
religiöse Gründe gibt eine Impfung für
sich persönlich abzulehnen wer wehren
wir wenn wir diese Gründe im Sinne des
allgemeinschutzes als nicht zulässig
erachten würden insbesondere dass wir
mittlerweile wissen dass der fremdschutz
durch eine Impfung kaum mehr gegeben ist
auch deshalb fällt es mir schwer bei der
Impfung von einem Akt der Solidarität zu
sprechen wie es viele tun weil Impfung
keine sterile Immunität liefert dient
sie zuallererst dem Selbstschutz wir tun
gut daran die Impfung nicht durch eine
moralische Aufladung sondern
solidaritätspflicht zu machen denn damit
würden wir sie zwangsläufig politisieren
und Menschen die persönliche Gründe
gegen eine Impfung anführen können
stigmatisieren und zu Karies der
Gesellschaft machen
Kollegen im Kern geht es heute deshalb
auch um die Minderheitenschutz der durch
eine impfpflich berührt wird ich möchte
jedenfalls nicht dass die Mehrheit für
die Minderheit festlegt was man als
vernünftig anzusehen hat und was man
nach mehrheitsman und tun muss um
solidarisch zu sein denn wenn die
Minderheit von der Mehrheit in
grundrechtssensiblen Fragen unter
Rückgriff auf eine höhere Moral einfach
überstimmt wird dann können wir nur
hoffen dass wir nie in die Verlegenheit
kommen werden Teil einer Minderheit zu
sein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gibt
gute Gründe für die Impfung die für eine
Impfpflicht überzeugen mich nicht weder
droht ein Kollaps das Gesundheitssystems
bei massiv steigender Infektionszahlen
sinken die Behandlungszahlen auf den
Intensivstationen noch kann eine
Impfpflicht noch etwas zu Bewältigung
der omegon-welle beitragen ein massiven
Grundrechtseingriff mit einer möglichen
Mutant im Herbst zu begründen die wir
noch nicht kennen und an den Impfstoff
die wir noch nicht haben sozusagen eine
Impfpflicht auf Vorrat halte ich auch
aus rechtlicher Sicht für nichtvertreter
vielen Dank
war das er hat einen Gruppenantrag
initiiert und plädiert gegen eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht
[Applaus]
er hat gerade formuliert
was ihn dazu bewogen hat
übrigens auch für sie gilt das Zeichen
Präsident wenn das aufläuft
[Applaus]
nächster Redner ist der Abgeordnete
Matthias W birkwald aus der Fraktion DIE
LINKE
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen seit 25 Jahren
lasse ich mich jedes Jahr gegen Grippe
impfen ich habe nahezu alle von der
Ständigen Impfkommission empfohlenen
Impfung erhalten das sind weit über 20
und ich bin selbstverständlich
vollständig geimpft und ich habe mich
bewusst Boostern lassen obwohl ich seit
sieben Monaten Schmerzen an der
Einstichstelle nach der zweiten Impfung
verspüre und obwohl mein Vater
einen Tag nach seiner Impfung gegen
kovid 19 verstorben ist was offiziell
keinen Zusammenhang mit der Impfung
hatte sich aber nach wie vor völlig
anders anfühlt ich habe also eine
individuelle Risikoabwägung vorgenommen
und mich im Anschluss für die Impfung
entschieden ich halte diese freie
Entscheidung für den richtigen Weg für
alle erwachsenen Menschen in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
eine Entscheidung für oder gegen eine
Impfung gegen Kurve 19 sollte immer
selbstbestimmt und individuell nach der
Aufklärung über persönliche Chancen und
Risiken getroffen werden können ich
werbe dafür die individuellen
demokratischen Grundrechte der freien
Persönlichkeitsentfaltung und der
körperlichen Unversehrtheit der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger unseres
demokratischen und sozialen
Rechtsstaates keinesfalls durch eine
Impfpflicht gegen kovid 19
einzuschränken
ich werde für einen rationalen und einen
humanistischen Umgang mit der
corona-pandemie und ich bin nicht in
jedem Fall gegen eine Impfpflicht bei
der sinnvollen masernimpflicht habe ich
mich enthalten weil Verstöße gegen die
Impfpflicht mit 2.500 Euro sanktioniert
werden diese Summe müssen
investmentbankerinnen genauso zahlen wie
Hartz IV Betroffene und als Linker sage
ich das ist zutiefst sozial ungerecht
wir linken stehen für die soziale
Teilhabe aller Menschen wenn das Bußgeld
aber beispielsweise wieder 2.500 Euro
betrüge dann könnten sich die
Wohlhabenden von der impfpflichtfrei
kaufen aber Paketboten Kassiererinnen
Reinigungskräfte und Kellner könnten
dies nicht tun nach gegenwärtigem recht
drohte ihnen sogar nach mehrfacher
Weigerung Bußgelder zu zahlen eine
Erzwingungshaft im Gefängnis liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dazu darf es
auf gar keinen Fall kommen
es geht auch Unglaubwürdigkeit
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hatte seinerzeit
eine allgemeine impfpflichtkategorisch
ausgeschlossen im Januar 2021 konnte man
auf der Internetseite des
Bundesgesundheitsministeriums lesen nein
es wird keine allgemeine Impfpflicht
geben Zitat Ende ich stehe für eine
glaubwürdige Politik ich habe dies
meinen Wählerinnen und Wählern in Köln
vor der Wahl versprochen und werde mich
jetzt auch nach der Wahl daran bei
meinem
Abstimmungsverhalten erinnern ich komme
zum Schluss liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
bitte tun Sie dies auch denn hier geht
es um Vertrauensschutz aktuell heißt es
ja es werde keinen Impfzwang geben wer
soll denn das noch glauben wenn die
Aussage eine Impfpflicht sei
ausgeschlossen schon nach so kurzer Zeit
nicht mehr das Papier wert ist auf dem
sie gedruckt wurde nein diese
Impfpflicht ist eine autoritäre Illusion
besser als diese Impfpflicht wäre es die
Menschen zu überzeugen ich danke Ihnen
Matthias birkwald war das der aus den
Reihen der Linken Sprache aber es gibt
ja hier keine einheitliche Meinung bei
vielen Fraktionen bei anderen es ist
anders wie sie verfolgen können was in
Zeitplan anbelangt abgestimmt wird ja
heute nicht über die Anträge über die
gruppenanträge soll in der Sitzungswoche
ab dem 14 Februar dann beraten werden im
März wahrscheinlich wird dann ein
Beschluss hier fallen frau Präsidentin
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
bevor ich mit der inhaltlichen Debatte
anfangen möchte ich doch eine Sache
loswerden
wer diese Debatte heute verfolgt der
wird feststellen in was für eine
lebhaften Demokratie wir sind und dass
wir in solch eine Debatte in einer
Diktatur gar nicht führen würden das was
nämlich einige Verschwörungstheoretiker
und einige demokratiefeinde in diesem
Land behaupten meine Damen und Herren
ich möchte
ich möchte meine Aufmerksamkeit bei
meinen Redebeitrag den Einrichtungen der
Eingliederungshilfe und den und für die
Menschen mit Behinderung widmen wir
haben ungefähr vor eineinhalb Monaten
die Parzelle Impfpflicht eingeführt die
wird bestimmte Konsequenzen mit sich
bringen das spüren wir teilweise das
bringt das hört man auch in der in den
Diskussionen mit der freien
Wohlfahrtspflege auch ich möchte aber
auch darstellen dass nicht die Parzelle
Impfpflicht das Problem ist sondern dass
insbesondere in der Eingliederungshilfe
seit 30 40 Jahren nicht nachgegangenen
neuen Infrastrukturen das Problem sind
wir haben teilweise eine
Refinanzierungsstruktur in der
Behindertenhilfe gehabt die lässt sich
wirklich zu wünschen übrig ich habe ihn
mal sogar mal heute einen Rechenbeispiel
mitgebracht wie wir es in
Baden-Württemberg haben stellen Sie sich
mal vor einem 24er Wohnheim bei einem
Personalschlüssel von 1 zu 2,54 das
bedeutet
9,44 voll vorstellen und die
landespersonalverordnung in
Baden-Württemberg sagt davon darf nur 50
Prozent die Fachkräfte sein das bedeutet
dass ich 4,77 Fachkräfte habe und 4,77
Hilfskräfte und die darf ich dann auch
noch mal in drei Wohngruppen verteilen
bitte sehen Sie das nach meine Damen und
Herren wenn wirklich von diesen Menschen
ein zwei Personen dann die Einrichtung
verlassen dass das weh tut das tut den
Einrichtungen weh aber deshalb müssen
wir auch hingehen und sagen naja wo
wandert denn das Personal hin sie
wandern aktuell in die übrigen
Hilfestrukturen in die Jugendhilfe in
die Obdachlosenhilfe da wo sie eben
momentan eine arbeitsheimat finden
können erschweren kommt noch hinzu wenn
sie auch noch ein Wahlkreis haben wie
ich Lörrach Mülheim an der Schweizer
Grenze dass die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sagen naja da fahre ich halt mal zehn
Minuten rüber und schafft bislang der
Schweiz ja und das erschwert eben
zusätzlich die Situation in den
Einrichtungen aber wir können das
Problem lösen wir können das Problem
nämlich mit einer allgemeinen Pflicht
lösen weil dann muss sich jeder
verpflichten in diesem Land der in
diesen Hilfestrukturen auch arbeiten
möchte auch hier eben seinen Beitrag zu
leisten meine Damen und Herren
und was vielleicht zusätzlich auch noch
erschwerend auch noch dazu kommt ist der
übrige Umstand dass die Einrichtungen
und auch die Menschen mit Behinderung
selber oder Ihre Angehörigen auch Sorgen
darüber haben was passiert denn wenn die
Gesundheitsämter in den Einrichtungen
jetzt ihren Ermessensspielraum auch noch
ausüben wir haben in Baden-Württemberg
beispielsweise 44 statt und Landkreise
die dann zuständig sind dann machte eine
Landkreis dass das Gesundheitsamt dort
und der andere Landkreis entscheidet
dann das das bringt Unsicherheiten auch
hier können wir sagen wenn wir eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht haben werden wir
auch die Probleme der Patienten
Impfpflicht aufheben können und damit
auch Sicherheit schaffen bei den
Leistungserbringern bei den
Leistungsberechtigten und bei den
Leistungsträgern meine Damen und Herren
zumal zumal wir ja auch noch
gegebenenfalls auch auch eine Struktur
hin steuern dass ich selber
konkurrierendes Ordnungsrecht nenne wir
werden auf der einen Seite die
landesspezifischen Regelungen haben wie
beispielsweise die heimgesetze die dann
die Einrichtungen dazu verpflichten eben
Leistungsverpflichtung gegenüber den
Menschen mit Behinderung nachzukommen
aber wenn dann das Personal ausfällt
weil sie vielleicht auch krank werden
weil sie sich angesteckt haben wird es
dazu führen dass das andere Personal ja
mehr gefordert wird was passiert dann
wenn das Arbeitszeitgesetz nicht
eingehalten werden kann das heißt ich
habe auf der einen Seite das Heimgesetz
auf der anderen Seite das
Arbeitszeitgesetz zwei
ordnungsrechtliche Rahmenbedingungen die
miteinander konkurrieren die
Einrichtungen die Menschen mit
Behinderung wissen heute immer noch
nicht was dann die Konsequenz sein wird
und auch hier können wir sagen wenn die
Verantwortung für diese Menschen mit
Behinderung die in Einrichtungen leben
oder auch die alleine leben den Dienst
die Leistung der Dienste noch in
Anspruch nehmen können können wir sagen
wer die Verantwortung übernimmt der wird
auch hier für die Menschen mit
Behinderung auch weiterhin die Leistung
erbringen können
die Zeit ist schon vorbei das ist das
ist schon länger vorbei das ist das
Zeichen davon sehr sehr ärgerlich meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ich
appelliere auch an die Menschen die in
den Einrichtungen arbeiten lassen Sie
uns gemeinsam für die Menschen mit
Behinderung da sein ich hätte ihn ja
noch so viel Wichtiges erzählt aber das
mache ich dann noch ein andermal vielen
Dank fürs zuhören
mit Ali war das aus den Reihen der SPD
kommt er und sollen ja möglichst viele
Abgeordnete hier heute in dieser
orientierungsdebatte zu Wort kommen
Gegner Befürworter solche mit Mittelweg
aber aus solche die noch nicht
entschieden sind nächster Redner jetzt
aus der Union Sepp Müller
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
morgen vor zwei Jahren jagt sich zum
zweiten Mal der erste positive
corona-fall in Deutschland und ich
glaube mittlerweile ist doch allen
bewusst dass es keine Gewissheit in der
Ungewissheit gibt ja auch wir hier im
Hohen Haus hatten damals teilweise
Annahmen die sich im Nachgang nicht
richtig bewiesen haben ja auch wir in
dem Hohen Haus haben Fehler gemacht
wir haben Entscheidungen getroffen die
wir vielleicht zwei Jahre später so
nicht mehr treffen
und nun
mit Blick auf die Beschlüsse der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz unterstützt
durch den Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
debattieren wir die Einführung einer
Impfpflicht
dieser Beschluss ist im November letzten
Jahres gefasst worden
in einer hoch tödlichen Variante der
Delta Variante
der Anlass zur Annahme gab dass die
Gesundheitsämter nicht nur belastet sind
sondern vor allem dass unsere
Gesundheitssystem überlastet wird
und daraufhin ist zu Recht gesagt worden
unsere impflücke ist zu groß wir müssen
diese impflücke schließen haben wir
schon alles im Vorfeld geklärt und diese
impflücke schließen zu können deswegen
soll sich der Deutsche Bundestag auch
mit der Impfpflicht beschäftigen um die
impflücke zu schließen mittlerweile
schreiben wir Ende Januar und es ist
eine andere Variante vorherrschen die
omicon Variante
es gibt unterschiedliche Auffassungen
zwischen Virologen
zwei prominente einer davon
Bundesgesundheitsminister geht davon aus
dass wir eine rekombinierte Variante im
Herbst haben
andere Virologen
sagen dass wir mit der Omicron Variante
in eine endemische Lage kommen werden
nichts ist gewiss in der Ungewissheit
wie sollen wir damit verfahren und
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir hier
als Parlament diese Debatte führen damit
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger dort draußen
die Argumente sehen die dafür und
dagegen sprechen
aber genauso richtig ist es in einer so
kritischen Situation wie wir uns
befinden dass man von einer
Bundesregierung Führung erwarten kann
genauso richtig und wichtig ist es dass
man von einer Bundesregierung in so
einem Fall einen Vorschlag erwarten kann
genauso richtig und wichtig ist es dass
man Fragen beantwortet ich habe sehr
aufmerksam zugehört liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sehr aufmerksam sowohl die
Befürworter der Impfpflicht als acht ab
18 als auch die Befürworter aus der
Ampel der Impfpflicht ab 50 wie soll
denn die Umsetzung erfolgen wollen wir
die Gesundheitsämter damit wieder
beschäftigen wie soll am Ende der
Vollzug
geschafft werden Bußgeld Beugehaft
Zwangsimpfung ab wann soll die
allgemeine Impfpflicht ab 18 oder 50
gelten
ab welchem Alter ist geklärt aber ab
welchem Zeitpunkt wie wollen wir
diejenigen anschreiben und kontaktieren
unsere Datengrundlage ist schlecht
75,5 Prozent sind mindestens geimpft und
wenn ich jetzt schon die Zwischenrufe
von Bündnis 90 der Grünen höhere freue
ich mich dass auch der
baden-württembergische Ministerpräsident
zu einem Schluss gekommen ist ein
impfregister einzuführen wir brauchen
eine bessere Datengrundlage
und mit dieser besseren Datengrundlage
können wir auch viel dezidierter auf
diejenigen zugehen mit denen wir
sprechen können deren sorgen wir nehmen
können mit denen wir Überzeugung auch
leisten können in einen individuellen
Arztgespräch weil mit zukünftig neu
zugelassenen Impfstoffen einem
proteinimpfstoff der jetzt in der
nächsten Woche übernächsten Woche
geliefert wird mit einem zusätzlichen
Impfstoff einen Tod im Stoff der Kombat
können wir auch diejenigen erreichen um
die impflücke zu schließen
und dann muss die Frage erlaubt sein und
diese Frage konnte die Bundesregierung
auf unsere Kleine Anfrage nicht leisten
diese Antwort auf diese Frage weil
nichts ist gewiss in der Ungewissheit
wie wird denn die Impfung auf nächste
Varianten wirken jetzt gibt es den
Vorschlag aus der Ampel ab 18 reichen
drei Impfungen für die nächsten zwei
Jahre wir wissen aber mittlerweile schon
dass in der Omegon Variante die Impfung
hilft gegen die Einlieferung auf die
Intensivbetten impfen ist die Entlastung
für unsere Pflegerinnen und Pfleger aber
die Impfung hilft halt nicht gegen die
Ansteckung
und deswegen ist das Festhalten auf drei
Impfung bei der Vorschlag der hier
gemacht wird schwierig
schwierig wir gehen wieder in ein
Versprechen an die Bevölkerung was wir
wahrscheinlich
wenn der Virologe und
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach Recht hat dass wir eine
rekombinierte Variante im Herbst
Erwarten nicht eingehalten werden kann
und der Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach hat den ärmsten Ländern wie
Rumänien fünf Millionen zusätzliche
Dosen weggenommen auf unsere Kleine
Anfrage steht 142 132 Millionen Dosen
könnten wir am ersten Quartal in
Deutschland vor impfen da wollen wir
denn demnächst der Hund und Katze impfen
die rekombinierten Varianten ja
Lauterbach und ich freue mich dass Sie
zukünftig ja auch noch reden werden ich
hoffe auch als Bundesgesundheitsminister
entstehen doch dort wo die Impfquoten so
niedrig sind warum ist es nicht unsere
Aufgabe die 132 Millionen Impfdosen die
wir bedauerlicherweise nicht alle
verimpfen können im ersten Quartal den
ärmsten Ländern dieser Welt zur
Verfügung zu stellen um dort die
rekombinierten Varianten zu verhindern
das ist doch unsere Aufgabe und deswegen
ist es gut dass wir die Debatte hier
führen deswegen ist es gut dass auch
zwei Bundesländer
mit CDU Beteiligung das impfregister
Führen mit dem Ziel die erstimpfquote
nach oben zu bringen und daran werden
wir auch konstruktiv mitarbeiten
herzlichen Dank
Sepp Müller war das für die
Unionsfraktion
der ebenfalls noch mal bekräftigt hat es
soll doch ein impfregister geben
aus den Reihen der Grünen
mit seinem Redebeitrag
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
geschätzten Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lieber Herr Müller ich kann Ihnen sagen
wo der Ort ist wo ihre guten Fragen
beantwortet werden und zwar dort wo an
den gruppenanträgen gearbeitet wird das
sage ich Ihnen als einer der sieben
Initiatoren für den Antrag Impfpflicht
ab 18 und diejenigen die hier an der
Impfpflicht ab 50 Arbeiten die heißen
sie auch sehr herzlich willkommen melden
Sie sich sie haben sich hier zu erkennen
gegeben unsere
Abgeordneten hier daran arbeiten machen
Sie mit
die Frage ist doch wo stehen wir heute
in einem Jahr werden wir mit einem
Gefühl des Aufbruchs in das Jahr 2023
Staaten weil wir wissen dass dieses Jahr
anders sein wird oder befinden wir uns
in den gleichen Irrungen und Wirkungen
der Pandemie wie heute das alles hängt
maßgeblich von unseren Handlungen und
politischen Entscheidungen in diesem
Jahr ab
die Wissenschaft ist auf unserer Seite
162 Millionen verabreichte Impfdosen in
Deutschland sind schon eine gewaltige
Leistung aber es reicht nicht es reicht
nicht für den endemischen Zustand der
Pandemie uns reicht nicht für eine
Planbarkeit unseres Lebens für Kinder
Jugendliche und junge Erwachsene sind
die letzten Jahre eine
unwiederbringliche Zeit des Stillstands
gerade ihnen müssen wir einen Aufbruch
ermöglichen
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht ist die
Brücke über die wir gehen müssen nachdem
so viele bereits geimpfte Menschen nun
ihren Beitrag zur Bekämpfung der
Pandemie geleistet haben und mit ihrer
Impfung abgestimmt haben sind nun die
anderen dran nur eine höhere Impfquote
wird uns unsere Freiheit zurückgeben die
Freiheit unser Leben zu gestalten und zu
planen
Perikles sagte das Geheimnis des Glücks
ist die Freiheit und das Geheimnis der
Freiheit ist der Mut und hier brauchen
wir den Mut uns zu entscheiden für eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht für Freiheit von
uns allen und für stabile Perspektiven
es geht um eine millionenfach erprobt
und sichere Impfung und es geht um die
Gesundheit von uns allen es ist klar
dabei dass diese Impfpflicht kein
geringer Eingriff ist aber es ist die
viel größere Zumutung das notwendige
Operationen verschoben werden müssen
Menschen mit Herzinfarkt oder
Schlaganfall keine adäquatische
medizinische Behandlung bekommen oder
gar an den mittelbaren Folgen eines
überlasteten Gesundheitssystems sterben
ein gut funktionierendes
Gesundheitssystem das basiert immer auf
dem Prinzip der Solidarität jeder und
jede muss sein und ihren Beitrag leisten
mit der allgemeinen Impfpflicht fordern
wir diese Solidarität von allen ein
und natürlich braucht es auch Kontrollen
genauso wie bei anderen corona-maßnahmen
muss auch die Impfpflicht kontrolliert
werden die Durchsetzung ist ein großes
Thema richtige Fragen die gestellt
worden sind aber wir wissen doch dass
Bußgelder effektiv sind und
funktionieren auch bei Tempolimits
werden etwa effektiv mit Bußgeldern
durchgesetzt die Pandemie die geht uns
alle an und nur gemeinsam kommen wir da
auch wieder raus wir liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen haben hier die
Verantwortung dass sie an einem Jahr
nicht wieder über neue Maßnahmen und
lockdowns diskutieren müssen dass wir
vor allem in jungen Generationen ihre
Freiheit zurückgegeben haben und ein
funktionierendes Gesundheitswesen haben
ich möchte dass wir hier in einem Jahr
stehen und sagen gut dass wir uns für
die Impfpflicht entschieden haben
ich bin überzeugt wir können diese
impfpflichtverfassungsgemäß ausgestalten
und ich lade Sie nochmals alle sehr
herzlich ein an diesen gemeinsamen
Initiativen in den verschiedenen Gruppen
mitzuarbeiten mein ganz herzlichen Dank
die Rede von T steffen war das der sich
hier für eine Impfpflicht ab 18 Jahren
eingesetzt hat die afd-fraktion hat
schon angekündigt dass sie gegen eine
Impfpflicht ist für die Fraktion spricht
jetzt Jörg Schneider
sagen ich möchte mich mit den impfen
Nebenwirkungen beschäftigen vor allen
Dingen mit der Herzmuskelentzündung das
Thema wird in regierungsfreundlichen
Medien gerne ein bisschen runtergespielt
das redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland
schreibt zum Beispiel dazu naja eine
Herzmuskelentzündung die gibt es
beispielsweise auch nach einer
corona-infektion und da ist sie sogar
viermal so häufig wie nach einer Impfung
meine Damen und Herren wer so
argumentiert der Macht direkt zwei
Fehler der erste große Fehler Corona
kennt eigentlich keine
Durchschnittswerte wir wissen eine
corona-infektion des für ältere Menschen
sehr gefährlich für jüngere Männer
hingegen kaum sie entwickeln nur selten
Symptome und erst recht nur ganz selten
schwere Symptome wie eine
Herzmuskelentzündung wir wissen aber
auch dass die Nebenwirkung einer
Herzmuskelentzündung insbesondere junge
Männer besonders häufig trifft 10 bis 20
Mal so häufig wie den Durchschnitt meine
Damen und Herren wenn wir die Risiken
von impfen von Impfungen und Infektion
miteinander vergleichen wollen dann
müssen wir mit einbeziehen Werte wie
Alter wie Geschlecht wie Vorerkrankungen
und eine so differenzierte
Vorgehensweise die ist nur möglich
solange die Impfentscheidung frei ist
meine Damen und Herren
und das rnd macht einen zweiten Fehler
es vergleicht das Risiko einer Impfung
mit dem Risiko einer Infektion nur wir
sind denn die Zahlen aus das RKI sagt
bisher haben sich ungefähr zehn Prozent
der Menschen in Deutschland mit Corona
infiziert es gibt dann
dunkelzifferpacken wenn du mal 10% drauf
das sind 20 Prozent in zwei Jahren das
ist zehn Prozent pro Jahr also
statistisch erkrankt jeder einmal in
zehn Jahren oder infiziert sich einmal
in zehn Jahren mit Corona und wir oft
müssen wir geimpft werden wenn den
Empfehlungen der Regierung gefolgt ist
der ist jetzt schon dreimal geimpft und
die Impfstoffhersteller testen gerade an
Omicron angepasste Impfstoffe sie sagen
da brauchen wir eine weitere Dosis naja
wer es glaubt aber glauben wir es mal
dann sind das vier Dosen in gut einem
Jahr alle vier Monate eine Impfung und
jetzt vergleichen wir statistisch einmal
in zehn Jahren das Risiko einer
Infektion und in zehn Jahren statistisch
30 Impfungen das heißt es ist Grund
falsch das Risiko einer Impfung zu
vergleichen mit dem Risiko einer
Infektion sondern wir müssen das Risiko
einer Infektion vergleichen mit dem
30-fachen Risiko der Impfung und dann
sieht die Risikobewertung vollkommen
anders aus und dann kann eigentlich die
Antwort nur noch lauten nein es darf
keine Impfpflicht geben meine Damen und
und erlauben Sie mir abschließend ein
paar persönliche Worte
ich bin vor drei Jahren an Krebs
erkrankt das ist glimpflich verlaufen
ich stehe in engmaschiger Nachsorge und
voriges Jahr stellte sich für mich dann
natürlich auch die Frage lässt du dich
jetzt impfen ich habe mich informiert
ich habe mich mit meinem behandelnden
Arzt unterhalten und bin zu dem
Entschluss gekommen jawohl ich lasse
mich impfen
aber ich möchte dass alle Menschen in
Deutschland so wie ich diese
Entscheidungsfindung durchführen können
dass Sie sich informieren können dass
Sie sich beraten lassen können und dass
sie dann frei eine Entscheidung treffen
die sich für Sie persönlich richtig und
gut anfühlt meine Damen und Herren
ich bitte sie lassen sie den Menschen in
Deutschland die Freiheit lassen sie den
Menschen in Deutschland die Freiheit das
Recht frei zu entscheiden ob sie sich
impfen lassen wollen oder nicht ich
danke Ihnen
Jörg Schneider war das für die
afd-fraktion hat hier noch mal darum
geworben keine Impfpflicht einzuführen
das hier ist ja erstmal eine Debatte
eine erste orientierungsdebatte drei
Stunden lang und in dieser spricht jetzt
Andrew Ullmann für die FDP der auch
einen Antrag ausarbeitet für eine
Impfpflicht ab 50 Jahren
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir sind in eine Situation für die uns
Generation vor uns beneidet hätten wir
haben einen wirksamen Impfstoff in einer
Pandemie mit diesem impfprivileg können
wir schreckliche gesundheitliche
wirtschaftliche und gesellschaftliche
Folgen abwehren
die Entwicklung eines effektiven und
sicheren Impfstoffes gegen sarskow 2 war
unter anderem eine mega Leistung einer
kleinen Firma aus Mainz ich würde sogar
sagen die rasche Impfstoffentwicklung
ist eine der größten Leistungen der
Medizin in den letzten 100 Jahren und
trotzdem ist und trotzdem ist die
heutige Diskussion zu Impfpflicht
notwendig unser gemeinsames Ziel muss
die schnellstmögliche Rückkehr in den
Freiheitlichen Normalzustand sein ohne
dabei das Gesundheitssystem kollabiert
hierbei steht uns derzeit zwei Wege
offen zum einen die sogenannte
natürliche Durchseuchung ein durchaus
gefährliches Unterfangen zum anderen die
wissenschaftliche erwiesene Immunität in
weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung durch
Impfungen
ich bin als Arzt
ich als Arzt bin ich es gewöhnt
lösungsorientiert zum Wohle der
Patientinnen und Patienten zu handeln
deswegen schließe ich aus das Virus
gewähren zu lassen der menschliche
wirtschaftliche Schaden wer unabsehbar
es bleibt nur der Weg über die Impfungen
das ist übrigens auch der Grundtenor der
fachwissenschaftlichen Community hierbei
ist uns aber wichtig alles zu versuchen
um die Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu
überzeugen sie mitzunehmen wir wollen
den Menschen nur als ultima ratio zu
Vernunft verpflichten
zuvor halte ich es für unsere Pflicht
die Argumente darzulegen wir als
staatlicher Verantwortungsgemeinschaft
müssen alles versuchen um jener
relevanten Anteil an impfskeptiker zu
überzeugen wir haben die Vernunft und
die wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse auf
unserer Seite
deshalb schlagen wir eine verpflichtende
Aufklärungsgespräch vor es gibt eine
große Anzahl von ein ungeimpften
Menschen die überzeugt werden können
ein relevanter Teil der Bevölkerung
fühlt sich immer noch unzureichend über
die Kurve 19 Impfung informiert diese
wollen wir in einem ersten Schritt
erreichen eine verpflichtendes
professionelles und persönliches
Beratungsgespräch für alle ungeimpfte
Erwachsene in Deutschland ist notwendig
und ich möchte sagen dass diese Menschen
nicht nur die Pflicht haben sich beraten
zu lassen diese Menschen haben auch ein
Recht darauf wertfreie und seriöse
Informationen zu erhalten diese Maßnahme
ist angemessen verhältnismäßig und
geeignet für das wichtige Ziel mehr
Menschen von der Impfung zu überzeugen
und so die gesundheitliche Versorgung
bundesweit zu gewährleisten
sollte sollten wir die notwendige
Impfquote durch professionelle
Aufklärung nicht erreichen muss ein
weiterer Schritt umgesetzt werden ein
altersabhängiger impfnachweispflicht zum
Beispiel ab 50 Jahren wenn die
Krankenhausversorgung gefährdet ist ist
dieses Mittel angemessen und
erforderlich eine Altersgrenze wird
dabei nicht willkürlich gewählt mit
einer wissenschaftlich belegten
Altersgrenze als Vorgehensweise wäre ein
milderer staatlicher Eingriff als eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht ab 5 oder 18
Jahren gleichwohl wäre er ausreichend
effektiv meine Damen und Herren wir
müssen jetzt handeln statt wieder einmal
mit freiheitseinschränkungen behandelt
zu werden ich möchte Sie liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen herzlich
einladen dem interfraktionellen Weg
mitzuarbeiten herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
die Linksfraktion hat schon im
vergangenen Jahr angekündigt oder sich
für eine Impfpflicht für alle
Erwachsenen ausgesprochen der
Abgeordnete Gregor Gysi hat dort
allerdings eine andere Meinung und die
wird er jetzt hier im Plenum noch mal
erläutern
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Einigkeit im Haus abgesehen von
einer Fraktion besteht ja darin dass
Impfung gegen das Coronavirus sinnvoll
sind weil sie vor schweren
Krankheitsverläufen und dem Tod
wenigstens für eine bestimmte Zeit
schützen auch das Infektionsrisiko wird
verringert deshalb müssen wir der großen
Mehrheit der Menschen die sich impfen
lassen und damit einen Beitrag leisten
des Gesundheitssystem zu entlasten und
andere Menschen zu schützen
die impflichtdebatte hält aber der
Politik ein Spiegel vor und zeigt das
Versagen der beiden Regierung der
jetzchen und der letzten andere Länder
wie Portugal Spanien Dänemark haben viel
höhere Impfquoten ohne Pflicht in
Deutschland sind gegen erlebten wir
desorganisationen zuerst fehlende
Impfstoffe dann zu wenig Impfstellen
heute nicht wirklich belastbare Zahlen
alles ein Trauerspiel auch hierzulande
zeigt etwa Bremen mit einer linken
Gesundheitssenatorin dass man mit
Aufklärung direkter Ansprache aller
Bevölkerungsteile guter Organisation
eine Impfquote eine zweifach-impfquote
von 86,1 Prozent der Bevölkerung
erreichen kann schade dass nicht alle
diesen Weg gegangen sind
aus diesem und aus vielen anderen
Gründen bin ich gegen eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht Zwangs soll ja
ausgeschlossen werden und ich muss Ihnen
sagen körperliche Gewalt zur Impfung
wäre sowas von indiskutabel und
Grundgesetz Friedrich so offensichtlich
dass der Bundespräsident es niemals
unterschrieben
aber auch die allgemeine Impfpflicht ist
nur schwer mit dem Grundgesetz in
Übereinstimmung zu bringen dazu wurde
schon gesprochen außerdem haben wir ja
real etwa 11 Millionen ungeimpfte
Menschen über 18 Jahre wie viel
Ordnungsämter brauchen wir eigentlich um
das ganze irgendwie zu bewerkstelligen
und staatliche Aufgaben können wir nicht
einfach auf Unternehmen übertragen auch
das sieht das Recht nicht vor eine
Pflicht ohne Sanktion ist keine Pflicht
also ging es doch letztlich
wahrscheinlich nur als Sanktion um
Geldbußen aber wer nicht zahlt oder
nicht zahlen kann kriegt stattdessen
Ordnungshaft und abgesehen von der
sozialen Frage auf die Matthias Burgwald
zurecht hingewiesen hat ist es völlig
undenkbar dass wir ungeimpfte auf
irgendeinem Weg einsperren das erträgt
das verträgt unsere Gesellschaft nicht
es führte zu einer Vertiefung der
Spaltung der Gesellschaft und muss schon
deshalb verhindert werden
beim Impfen wichtig ist müssen wir einen
anderen Weg gehen Aufklärung Aufklärung
Aufklärung wenn wir die Hälfte geimpft
wäre bis zum Herbst werden wir ein
großes Problem los das bedeutete pro Tag
25.000 Menschen und das soll uns nicht
durch Aufklärung gelingen das kann ich
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen lassen
Sie mich am Schluss folgendes sagen
statt einer Impfpflicht benötigen wir
deutlich mehr Vertrauen sonst wird die
Demokratie immer mehr Schaden nehmen
23,4 Prozent nicht wählen werden
10,3% AFD wählende 8,7 Prozent wählten
bewusst Parteien die nicht in den
Bundestag einziehen weil sie alle alle
diese Gruppen mit der etablierten
Politik fertig sind und zwar von der CSU
bis einschließlich der Linken darüber
müssen wir uns sehr viel mehr Gedanken
machen
37,5 Prozent der Bevölkerung vertraut
der etablierten Politik nicht mehr
und fünf bis zehn Prozent werden
vielleicht normal aber
37,5% sind viel zu viele und wir müssen
uns wesentlich mehr Gedanken machen wie
man Vertrauen herstellen kann sich eine
allgemeinverständliche Sprache durch die
Angabe der wahren Beweggründe für
Entscheidungen durch die Überwindung des
gesamten Lobbyismus und vor allem durch
deutlich mehr Ehrlichkeit
Gregor Gysi hat hier zum Schluss noch
einmal für eine transparentere Politik
geworden um gegen Misstrauen in die
Politik
diese zu bekämpfen rascher NASA spricht
jetzt für die SPD-Fraktion es ist ihre
erste Rede hier im Deutschen Bundestag
sie ist Abgeordnete aus Dresden
Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
mir geht es heute nicht vorrangig um die
Entscheidung Impfpflicht ja oder nein
mir geht es viel mehr darum wie wir als
Gesellschaft weitermachen wollen ich
habe Menschen getroffen die sich
leidenschaftlich für ihre Mitmenschen
einsetzen Tests und Impfzentren
aufgebaut und betreut und Aufklärung
betrieben haben ich habe natürlich
Menschen kennengelernt die skeptisch
waren die unsicher waren ob dieser neuen
Situation die wir so ja alle noch nie
erlebt haben
ich habe aber natürlich auch Menschen
getroffen die gegen die Existenz oder
Gefahr des Coronavirus argumentiert
haben und ich will ehrlich sein es war
für mich teils unfassbar zu sehen wie
bereitwillig Menschen glauben dass das
alles nur eine große Verschwörung ist es
seien die schweren Krankheitsverläufe
und vielen Todesopfern ist beweist genug
das Corona eine echte Gefahr für unser
Leben ist
aber eine Sache verbindet uns wir sind
müde und für alle wollen unser normales
Leben zurück und das meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren ist so
einfach wie war erreichen wir am ehesten
durch einen kleinen Pieks mit sehr
großer Wirkung
es ist so sehr zumindest ich das in
mittlerweile dritten Jahr der Pandemie
eben keine persönliche Entscheidung mehr
ob ich mich impfen lasse oder nicht es
ist mittlerweile doch auch nicht mehr
die Frage ob ich mich mit dem Virus
infiziere sondern vielmehr wann ja mit
der Impfung sind wir nicht 100%ig vor
einer Ansteckung geschützt aber mit der
Impfung schützen wir uns vor schweren
oder tödlichen Krankheitsverläufen mit
der Impfung schützen wir auch unsere
Mitmenschen und leisten zugleich einen
großen Beitrag unser Gesundheitswesen zu
schützen das ist die Faktenlage die auch
wissenschaftlich untermauert ist die
Impfstoffe sind mehrfach getestet und
weltweit milliardenfach im Einsatz ich
will nicht behaupten dass Nebenwirkungen
nicht auftreten können aber bitte hören
wir doch endlich auf uns einander weiß
machen zu wollen dass die Impfung
wahnsinnig gefährlich oder gar tödlich
sei hunderte geimpfte Kolleginnen hier
im Haus und Millionen geimpfte in diesem
Land sind der Gegenbeweis und wenn dann
hier
und wenn dann hier im Hohen Haus Plakate
mit der Aufschrift Freiheit statt
Spaltung hochgehalten werden und wir
haben es heute wieder gehört dann frage
ich mich doch allen Ernstes wer es ist
der hier versucht Spaltung zu betreiben
sie sind es doch die gezielt
Falschinformationen streuen und mit
falschen Zahlen um sich werfen sie sind
es sie gezielt Angst und hetzen
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
verantwortlich dieser endlich bewusst
Ich komme aus Sachsen ein Bundesland das
seit Beginn der Pandemie knapp 14.000
Todesopfer zu beklagen hat und immer
wieder gerät Sachsen in die Schlagzeilen
zuletzt weil sogenannte Spaziergänger in
aufgerufen hatten an der Uniklinik in
Dresden auf zu marschieren und ich
möchte diesen Moment nutzen um den
mutigen Medizinstudent in den Danke zu
sagen die sich mutig vor ihre Klinik und
Patientinnen gestanden danke für mich
seid ihr echte Heldinnen
keine Demokratie lebt ohne die Debatte
und deshalb finde ich es richtig dass
wir heute hier zum ersten Mal über die
Einführung einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht
sprechen natürlich ist es keine einfache
Entscheidung aber ich wünsche mir dass
am Ende dieser Debatte steht dass wir
als Gesellschaft gemeinsam an unseren
Herausforderungen wachsen jetzt ist es
an uns werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
für unser Land zu entscheiden wie wir
aus dieser Krise herauskommen wollen
lassen Sie uns miteinander diskutieren
welchen Weg wir gemeinsam gehen müssen
um schnellstmöglich in ein normaleres
Leben zurückzukehren dieses Hohe Haus
ist genau der richtige Ort um uns in
dieser schwierigen Frage Orientierung zu
geben und das Für und Wieder abzuwägen
also lassen Sie uns einander vertrauen
einerseits dass der Staat seinen Teil
tut aber andererseits das auch wir als
Bürger in unseren Teil tun nämlich indem
wir uns impfen lassen die Impfung
schützt und es gelebte Solidarität und
das ist genau das was dieses Land
braucht eine solidaritätspritze vielen
Dank
drei Vorschläge gibt es bisschen lang in
die hier ausgearbeitet werden Entwürfe
gibt es vereinzelt schon einmal eine
Impfpflicht ab 18 Jahren einzuführen
eine Impfpflicht ab 50 Jahren
einzuführen und eben keine Impfpflicht
überhaupt einzuführen und zu dieser
Debatte spricht nun Günther Krings von
der Unionsfraktion
Frau Präsident immer sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren offene
Bundestagsdebatten gelten ja gemeinhin
als Sternstunde des Parlaments ob das so
eine wird wenn wir vielleicht in
anderthalb Stunden Wissen eines aber ist
schon jetzt klar es ist jedenfalls eine
dunkle Stunde der Bundesregierung weil
sie hier und heute endgültig ihre
Unfähigkeit ihren Unwillen wie die auch
wollen offenbaren den Parlament einen
Vorschlag zum Thema Impfpflicht
vorzulegen
mindestens zwei Dinge sind hierbei
auffällig erstens hatten sie offenbar
kein Problem damit die Impfpflicht für
medizinisches und
pflegepersonal-fraktionsantrag
durchzusetzen alle weiteren möglichen
Verpflichtungen halten sie dann aber für
derart sensibel dass sie Gewissensfragen
sein
sind also die Grundrechte von Ärztinnen
und Pflegern weniger wert als die von
anderen Menschen ich hoffe doch nicht
und zweitens wurde bislang in diesem
Haus immer aus seiner Mitte heraus
entschieden
etwa zu einer bioethischen Frage
gruppenanträge zu stellen die Ampel gibt
nun erstmals regierungsamtlich vor wo
eine Gewissensentscheidung greift und wo
gruppenanträge zu schreiben sind nicht
sehr parlamentarisch meine Damen und
Herren
ist jedenfalls dass diese heutige
Debatte ganz offensichtlich deshalb
orientierungsdebatte heißt weil sich
eine orientierungslose Bundesregierung
Hilfe suchend ans Parlament wendet meine
Damen und Herren
meine Damen und Herren wir als Union das
ist unser Selbstbewusstsein helfen gerne
das setzt aber voraus dass Sie uns als
Regierung das zur Verfügung stellen wozu
der von verfassungswegen ja nur eine
Regierung Zugriff haben kann die
Informationen aus und Expertise aus
Ministerien aus Behörden und es ist
wirklich unglaublich wenn die
Bundesregierung in einer hochkritischen
Phase dieser Pandemie es sind über einem
Monat nicht schafft dringende Fragen zu
einer Impfpflicht zu beantworten und
dann gestern wirklich bloß ausweichende
halbantworten versucht
kein Wunder
kein Wunder dass diese Bundesregierung
zu Impfpflicht keine eigene Position
bezieht wenn sie selbst offenbar gar
nicht Informationsgrundlage auch für
sich haben um das tun zu können
es reicht eben nicht wenn der
Bundeskanzler wie letzte Woche hier
geschehen
seine Privatmeinung zum Besten gibt wenn
und das ist eine Eminenz
verfassungsrechtliche Frage jetzt wenn
einer der zentralen Fragen in der
größten Krise der Nachkriegszeit die
Bundesregierung sich weigert eine eigene
Position zu beziehen dann ist die
Wertung Flucht aus der Verantwortung
noch das freundlichste was mir dazu
einfällt meine Damen und Herren
wir weisen einer nach Orientierung
Suchenden Regierung gerne den Weg beim
Thema Impfen ja Impfungen da sind wir
uns hoffentlich ganz großen Teils hier
einig sind der entscheidende Weg aus der
Pandemie fakt ist aber dass die
Impfquote in Deutschland nach wie vor zu
gering ist um das Ziel dieses Weges auch
zu erreichen
folgerichtig hat sich die neue
Bundesregierung auch im letzten Jahr
ehrgeizige Ziele gesetzt bis zum
Jahresende 30 Millionen Booster
Impfungen bis zum 7 Januar eine Quote
von 80 Prozent bei den erstimpfungen
Problem ist nur sie haben beide Ziele
verfehlt
osterimpfungen 25 Millionen
erstimpfungen Zieldatum einmal
verschoben jetzt wird es wohl zum
zweiten Mal verschoben das ist Fakt
Fakten können weh tun sie sind aber wahr
angesichts dieses Scheiterns der
Regierung liegt es nun noch da an eine
Impfpflicht zu denken
ob wann und wie
das Opfern und wie in der solchen
Impfpflicht muss aber wohl überlegt sein
es ist zwar nur ein kleiner Pieks den
wir Menschen zu muten aber es bleibt ein
Grundrechtseingriff eine Impfpflicht
muss also verfassungsrechtlich und
politisch gut begründet sein und dabei
muss sie insbesondere drei Fragen
beantworten erstens welches Ziel
verfolgen wir mit ihr unser
Verfassungsgericht hat jedenfalls
festgestellt dass die Funktionsfähigkeit
unseres Gesundheitssystems so wichtig
ist dass der Gesetzgeber handeln darf
und soll um dessen Überlastung zu
verhindern
zweitens muss die Impfpflicht geeignet
sein um im weiteren Verlauf der Epidemie
auch einen Unterschied zu machen hier
brauchen wir also seriöse Prognosen über
neue Mutationen und auch die
Fortentwicklung der Impfstoffe nicht
sicheres Wissen aber jedenfalls seriöse
Prognosen auf vernünftiger Daten und
faktengrundlage und drittens setzt eine
Impfpflicht voraus
dass sie auch administrierbar
durchsetzbar und notfalls auch
sanktionierbar ist andernfalls wäre sie
rechtlich schwer haltbar und würde
gesellschaftlich wohl nicht akzeptiert
werden und das heißt ganz konkret die
Bundesregierung muss ihre
Blockadehaltung gegen den unverzüglichen
Aufbau eines impfregisters aufgeben
überwinden sie ihre Register Phobie
krempeln Sie die Arme hoch und bauen Sie
dieses Register endlich auf
und auch nicht zuletzt wegen der
Zögerlichkeit der letzten Wochen kommt
für die aktuelle omegonvariante
offensichtlich eine Impfpflicht zu spät
aber natürlich ist nicht auszuschließen
dass wir mit weiteren coronawellen zu
tun haben
gemeinsam haben wir doch hoffentlich
eines gelernt in den letzten beiden
Jahren nicht nur die aktuelle Situation
ist täglich zu meistern sondern wir
brauchen eine vorausschauende und
vorsorgende Politik deshalb brauchen wir
aus meiner Sicht jetzt die Vorlage auch
eines vorratsgesetzes dass eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht eben noch nicht
unmittelbar einführen muss das aber alle
Regeln dazu schon einmal vorbereitet und
mit dem wir dann eben vorbereitet sind
für weitere Entwicklung wir müssen
besser vorbereitet sein wir müssen
vorausschauend meine Damen und Herren
in dem Falle kann man auch sobald sich
dann die Notwendigkeit und Geeignetheit
abzeichnet sehr schnell per
Bundestagsbeschluss eine solche Pflicht
scharfscheibe und meine Damen und Herren
aus Vorsorgegründen müssen wir jetzt
eben auch das eben genannte nationale
impfregister aufbauen um mehr
zur impfsituation zu wissen das hat noch
nichts mit Impfpflicht zu tun
um Menschen gezielt zum Impfen zu
ermutigen ja aber auch um für die
Durchsetzung von impfpflichten
jedenfalls vorbereitet zu sein meine
Damen und Herren und ich fordere deshalb
die Bundesregierung Auffinden sie
endlich ihre Orientierung hier in dieser
corona-krise verlieren Sie keine Zeit
mehr beim Aufbau eines impfregisters
bereiten Sie ein ordentliches Instrument
vor und weichen sie bei Fragen der
Opposition nicht länger aus sondern
sorgen sie endlich dafür dass das
gesamte Haus auch sie selber die
notwendige Informationsgrundlage hat
vielen herzlichen Dank
Günther Krings hat hier noch mal
deutlich kritisiert dass es von der
Bundesregierung keinen Gesetzentwurf
gibt und wir kommen zu einer weiteren
Premiere für Recorder lang die wird
nämlich jetzt von Bündnis 90 den Grünen
auch ihre erste Rede hier im Deutschen
Bundestag halten
sehr geehrte Frau beste Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn ich
vor 12 oder 24 Monaten hier gestanden
hätte dann hätte ich gegen eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht gesprochen und
auch heute noch wäre ich froh wenn sie
nicht notwendig wäre doch ich bin davon
überzeugt dass PolitikerInnen bereit
sein müssen zu lernen und auf eines sich
verändernde Realität zu reagieren und
diese Realität zeigt uns doch dass wir
eine verdammt hohe Impfquote brauchen um
der Überlastung unseres
Gesundheitssystems vorzubeugen und um zu
verhindern dass wir unkontrolliert von
Welle zu Welle rutschen und deshalb
stehe ich heute hier und werde dafür
dass wir das Hamsterrad diese Pandemie
durchbrechen und eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht ab 18 auf den Weg bringen
und ja das ist eine Frage der Freiheit
aber nicht nur eine abstrakte Abwägung
zwischen Freiheit und Solidarität
sondern es geht um die ganz konkrete
Frage welche Maßnahmen wir brauchen um
die größtmögliche Freiheit zu erreichen
denn auf der einen Seite steht der
Eingriff durch die Impfpflicht doch auf
der anderen Seite stehen die massiven
freiheitseinschränkungen durch die
Maßnahmen die immer wieder notwendig
sind von der Absage von
Kulturveranstaltungen bis zur Schließung
von Geschäften und diese Einschränkungen
die treffen uns alle egal ob geimpft
oder ungeimpft die allgemeine
Impfpflicht hat damit eine positive
freiheitsbilanz die allgemeinen
Impfpflicht schützt unsere Freiheit
doch dafür muss sie das langfristige
Ziel haben das aus der corona-pandemie
eine Endemie wird das heißt wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass weniger Maßnahmen
notwendig sind dafür reicht aus meiner
Sicht eine altes gestaffelte Impfpflicht
nicht dafür braucht es eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht und ich finde wenn wir eine
Impfpflicht einführen dann muss sie auch
wirken
und damit schützen wir gerade auch die
Freiheit von denen die in den letzten
zwei Jahren die stärksten Lasten
getragen haben der Eltern die jeden Tag
darüber entscheiden ob Sie eher die
psychische oder die körperliche
Gesundheit ihre Kinder schützen der
Frauen die auf Teilzeit gewechselt haben
und jetzt ein noch höheres altes Risiko
der Altersarmut Tragen der Jugendlichen
die teilweise ihre Kolleginnen oder
Kommilitonen nicht einmal mit denen
zusammen an einen Tisch saßen und die
kleinsten unserer Gesellschaft die doch
überhaupt nicht verstehen warum sie
immer wieder in Quarantäne müssen und ja
das sind nicht die lautesten das sind
nicht die die gerade auf die Straße
gehen und warum weil sie schlichtweg
nicht die Kraft dazu haben weil sie seit
fast zwei Jahren auf dem Zahnfleisch
gehen und weil sie immer wieder die
Folgen von politischer Unentschiedenheit
austragen mussten damit muss Schluss
sein diese Menschen brauchen endlich
eine Perspektive
und an den rechten Rand dieses Saals sie
können hier schreien und Sie können
schimpfen so viel Sie wollen sie werden
damit nicht verhindern dass die
Demokraten und Demokraten des Deutschen
Bundestages heute eine respektvolle und
eine komplexe Debatte zum Wohle der
Menschen in diesem Land führen denn
dadurch zeigen wir wozu dieses Parlament
in der L
denn bei der Debatte um die Impfpflicht
gibt es gute Argumente dafür und dagegen
es gibt nicht einfach nur richtig und
falschen es gibt nicht gut und böse doch
Politik muss auch in einer komplexen
Situation bereit sein schwierige
Entscheidungen zu treffen und ich will
nicht dass wir im Herbst wieder an der
gleichen Stelle stehen und alles noch
mal von vorne losgeht so viele Menschen
in diesem Land sind müde und sie sind
mürbe und sie haben es verdient dass wir
endlich vorausschauend handeln und
deshalb lassen Sie uns gemeinsam für
diese Menschen eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht ab 18 auf den Weg bringen
vielen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete lang
ja und da gibt es
fraktionsübergreifenden Applaus auch die
Anträge werden ja fraktionsübergreifend
erarbeitet
Seitz für die afd-fraktion Herr Seitz
ich möchte Sie nur darauf hinweisen auf
Ihren Wunsch ja auch hin also ihrer
Fraktion ab der zweiten Minute können
sie dann ihre Redezeit dort sehen
bitteschön
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin als
ungeimpfte Abgeordneter zweiter Klasse
muss ich von der Besuchertribüne
sprechen morgen bei der gelenkunde ist
mir gar die Anwesenheit verboten dieser
parlamentarisches Skandal ist jedoch
nichts im Vergleich zu den Schikanen den
alle als ungeimpft geltenden Bürger
ausgesetzt sind aber von dieser
Diskriminierung wegzukommen indem man
die Menschen zwingt sich immer und immer
wieder impfen zu lassen denn darauf
läuft es hinaus ist ein Irrweg denn die
Impfpflicht verstößt gegen das
Grundgesetz
ich verstehe durchaus warum viele in
diesem Haus für eine Impfpflicht sind
denn sie brauchen die Impfpflicht um vom
Staatsversagen in der corona-krise
abzulenken weil der Verlust der
Glaubwürdigkeit droht weil der Impfstoff
dafür schon verbindlich bestellt ist um
diejenigen zu besänftigen die sich schon
haben impfen lassen und vielleicht auch
um zu verhindern dass es eine
ausreichend große Kontrollgruppe in
Bezug auf die gesundheitlichen
Auswirkungen der Impfstoffe gibt
in aller Kürze fünf Aspekte warum eine
impfpflichtverfassungswidrig ist erstens
saskow 2 ist kein Killervirus es ist für
Risikogruppen hochgradig gefährlich aber
gerade für junge und gesunde Menschen
besteht kaum ein messbares Risiko Corona
ist mit einer Seuche wie den Pocken in
nichts vergleichbar 2
anders als bei Pocken oder Masern kann
das Ziel der Ausrottung des Virus auf
bevölkerungsebene nicht erreicht werden
weder Impfung noch Booster können
verhindern dass man das Virus verbreitet
an covid 19 auch schwererkrankt oder gar
stirbt drittens der Schutz vor schweren
Krankheiten ist kein zulässiges Ziel
einer Impfpflicht wenn der Staat schon
den Kranken im Regelfall nicht zur
Heilbehandlung zwingen kann ist ein
Zwang bei Gesunden zur reinen
präsentativen Maßnahmen erst Recht
ausgeschlossen und viertens
die zur Verfügung stehenden Impfstoffe
sind nicht hinreichend getestet und ihre
Sicherheit nicht gewährleistet noch
niemals gab es eine solche Häufung von
gemeldeten Impfkomplikationen bis hin zu
Todesfällen wie bei der corona-impfung
für viele ist spätestens mit Omicron die
Impfung so gefährlich wie das Virus
vielleicht sogar gefährlicher
fünftens es gibt keine Pandemie der
ungeimpften sondern manipulierte
Statistiken wie in Hamburg oder Bayern
die Belastung
für Ärzte und Pfleger ist unglaublich
hoch und Sie verdienen höchsten Respekt
eine wirkliche Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystems mit der Gefahr eines
Zusammenbruchs wegen Corona war aber nie
in Sichtweite es fiel mir schon seit
mindestens 20 Jahren die Regel das vor
allem Intensivstationen häufig am
Anschlag arbeiten die Wahrheit ist
während Bettenabbau immer noch
finanziell gefördert wird verschärft die
besondere Impfpflicht die
Personalsituation nochmals dramatisch
ein letzter Satz
Zwang schafft kein Vertrauen sondern
zerstört ist impfen muss freiwillig
bleiben darum Nein zur Impfpflicht
Freiheit statt Spaltung vielen Dank
Thomas Seitz hat hier von der Tribüne
gesprochen denn im Sitzungssaal gilt
zwei g plus wer sich hier nicht
ausweisen und möchte ist als
Abgeordneter eben auf der Tribüne
nächste Rednerin ist Katrin Helling klar
von der FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren
ich setze mich für eine allgemeine in
Pflicht ein ich mache das gerade als
Liberale als Juristin nicht
leichtfertigt denn natürlich sind
Pflichtimpfungen Eingriffe in das
Grundrecht auf körperliche
Unversehrtheit und körperliche
Selbstbestimmung aber meine Damen und
Herren was ist die Alternative
zur allgemeinen Impfpflicht Prof
Wissmann von der Universität Münster hat
sehr treffen formuliert die Impfpflicht
ist es mildere Mittel als den freien
Staat in Lockdown endlos Schleifen
abzuschaffen ich möchte nicht dass
unsere Kinder jeden Winter bangen müssen
ob und wie lange sie im Kita und Schule
gehen können ich möchte nicht dass meine
Generation sich fortwährend Sorgen um
die Gesundheit der Kinder und der oft
vor erkrankten Eltern machen muss und
das werden sie zugleich um ihre
wirtschaftliche Existenz fürchten muss
weil die Leute zum Beispiel nicht in
Gastronomie oder Einzelhandel gehen
und da ist ist es am Ende auch egal ob
die Leute deshalb zu Hause bleiben weil
sie es staatlich verordnet bekommen oder
weil sie ist aus eigener Vernunft heraus
tun ich möchte nicht dass krebskranke
auf notwendige Behandlung warten müssen
all diese Maßnahmen und Einschränkungen
sind auch Grundrechtseingriffe
und unser Gesundheitssystem Gerät an
seine Grenzen wenn eine große
corona-welle auf uns zu rollt wir können
uns auf den Kopf stellen das bekommen
wir so schnell nicht gelöst dann bleibt
zugespitzt formuliert die Wahl zwischen
impfen und schließen ich finde wir
müssen Kurve 19 zu einer beherrschbaren
zu einer handhabbaren Erkrankung machen
zu einer die nicht mehr die gesamte
Gesellschaft zum Stillstand bringt
die Impfung ist der wirksamste Schutz
gegen das Virus egal in welcher Mutante
auch bei Omikron verhindert eine
dreifache Impfung schwere Verläufe
Hospitalisierung Aufenthalte auf
Intensivstationen und Todesfälle richtig
ist das ältere Personen ein besonders
hohes Risiko haben an schweren Verläufen
zu erkranken eine altersbezogene
Impfpflicht ist dennoch keine Option
denn wer sich auf diese Gruppe
beschränkt läuft sehenden Auges in
Abgrenzungsschwierigkeiten und
Wertungswidersprüche
was ist denn mit dem 40-Jährigen Typ 2
Diabetiker was ist mit der 20-Jährigen
Schwangeren ihr Risiken sind genauso
hoch wie oder da höher als die rüstiger
Rentner eine alltagsbezogene Impfpflicht
ist natürlich auch nicht genauso wirksam
wie eine allgemeine Impfpflicht und es
gibt starke Stimmen in der Wissenschaft
die darauf hinweisen dass eine
Impfpflicht jenseits einer gewissen
altersschwelle bei den anderen
Altersgruppen genau den gegenteiligen
Effekt haben wird diese glauben dann
dass sie die ganze Frage nicht betreffe
sie sich nicht so dringend impfen lassen
müssten denn sie sind ja eben nicht von
der Pflicht erfasst
richtig ist auch dass wir keine
Glaskugel haben es kann sein dass wir
die Impfpflicht früher oder später nicht
mehr brauchen man kann sie andererseits
auch nicht von heute auf morgen
beschließen deswegen ist es
selbstverständlich dass wir fortwährend
streng prüfen ob eine Impfpflicht weiter
angemessen ist und ein Gesetz auch von
vornherein kurz befristen meine Damen
und Herren nach alledem halte ich die
allgemeinen Impfpflicht in unserer
Situation in der Abwägung für das
kleinste Übel und eine Chance
und gestatten Sie mir mit Blick auf die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
noch einen letzten Satz ich bin verdammt
froh dass ich einer Fraktion angehöre in
der ich einen gewissen haben darf vielen
Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
das mit dem gewissen klären wir jetzt
noch mal
als nächstes erhält das Wort
auch von der Tribüne der fraktionslose
Abgeordnete Matthias Helferich auch für
zwei Minuten und ihre zwei Minuten
werden auch sofort eingeblendet so dass
sie ihre Zeit sehen können bitteschön
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin meine Damen
und Herren in Tagen der Angst
Ausgrenzung und Spaltung davor der
Oberbürgermeister von Freital Uwe
Rumberg als Vorbild für den Umgang in
einer freiheitlichen Gesellschaft
angesehen werden mit folgenden Worten
lud er die im freiheitsbefürworter und
Skeptiker einer Impfpflicht zum Dialog
in sein Rathaus ein ich fordere alle
freitale auf allen freidenkenden
Menschen alles friedliche handeln und
leben zu lassen in unserer
freiheitlichen Gesellschaft darf niemand
ausgegrenzt werden ich respektiere die
die sich impfen lassen genauso wie die
die sich nicht impfen lassen das
Freiheitsverständnis dieses Mannes
sollte Ihnen als Volksvertreter Vorbild
sein wozu nämlich ihr impfdruck für
zeigt die 13-Jährige Jasmin aus Hagen
die Schülerin möchte keinen Unterricht
mehr mit ungeimpften mitschül besuchen
und verbringt die Unterrichtsstunden
lieber bei winterlichen Temperaturen an
der freien Luft ihre Mainstream-Presse
feiert Jasmin schon als Bräter Thunberg
der Impfpflicht Befürworter doch leider
ist dieses Mädchen letztlich nur
Opfer ihrer staatlich verordneten
angstpolitik und wenn sich Ihr
persönliches Freiheitsverständnis im
Winterschlaf befindet möge ihnen das
Grundgesetz helfen schon das
freiheitsprinzip unserer Verfassung gibt
im Hinblick auf eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht einen Abwägungsprozess vor
der Einzelne ist für die Senkung
allgemeiner Lebensrisiken nicht
verantwortlich und der Staat darf ihn
nicht durch freiheitseinschränkungen
dafür in Anspruch nehmen der Staat mag
wenn er dies für richtig hält durch
Ausbau des Gesundheitssystems und andere
eben nicht freiheitseinschränkende
Maßnahmen die vorhandenen
Gesundheitsrisiken einschließlich derer
durch sarskow 2 minimieren aber
freiheitseinschränkungen zur Minimierung
von Risiken die unterhalb des Levels
allgemein
akzeptierter Lebensrisiken bleiben sind
immer unverhältnismäßig wenn sie sich
gegen Personen richten die diese Risiken
eben nicht verursachen es ist eine
Perversion des Rechtsstaatsprinzips alle
ungeimpften als Gefährder anzusehen und
in ihre körperliche Integrität
einzudringen um Zwecke der Allgemeinheit
zu verfolgen der Mensch der Bürger des
Grundgesetzes ist von Geburt an nur mit
einem Impfstoff geimpft es ist das Recht
auf Freiheit und Selbstbestimmung jeder
einzelne Mensch entscheidet Kraft seiner
Autonomie welche Risiken er sich
aussetzen wird und dafür werden wir
kämpfen vielen Dank
so weiter mit hier ist helfere ich
vorher Mitglied der AFD mittlerweile
Fraktion zur los bekommt ihr aber auch
Applaus von anderen Abgeordneten für die
SPD spricht jetzt Martina Stamm Fiebig
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
jeder der klaren Verstand es ist
begreift dass die Impfung Schlüssel für
den erfolgreichen Kampf gegen die
Pandemie ist und bleibt
trotzdem ist die Impfquote immer noch
deutlich zu niedrig und wer sich nicht
gegen Corona impfen lässt ersetzt seine
eigene Gesundheit und die Gesundheit
anderer Menschen aufs Spiel als Resultat
der mangelnden Impfbereitschaft sind die
krankenhauskapazitäten erschöpft und vor
allem die Beschäftigten vollkommen
überlastet und nervlich nach zwei Jahren
Pandemie auch vollkommen am Ende
oft dauert es Stunden bis Patientinnen
und Patienten vom Rettungsdienst in
einer Klinik eingeliefert werden können
Eingriffe werden verschoben Therapien
verzögert und die der Diagnosestellung
verlangsamt mit schwerwiegenden Folgen
für Tausende von Patientinnen und
Patienten die nicht an Corona erkrankt
sind vielleicht machen Sie sich das mal
zu eigen
eine Impfpflicht kann eine Lösung für
dieses Problem sein wenn sie allen
verfassungsrechtlichen Grundsätzen
genügt und wenn sie entsprechend
umsetzbar und auch ganz wichtig
durchsetzbar ist
in diesem Zusammenhang war in den
letzten Wochen oft und häufig das Wort
im Register zu hören
ich möchte diese Debatte zum Anlass
nehmen auch heute für die Einführung
eines zentralen impfregisters zu werben
und Liebe Union von ihnen müssen wir uns
das nicht anhören sie hatten acht Jahre
Gelegenheit und wir hätten es schon
lange haben können
[Musik]
nur so können wir nämlich
ja 2017 hat zersparen angekündigt nur
mal so nur so ließe sich die Einhaltung
nämlich der impflacht Impfpflicht in
Deutschland sehr sehr praktisch umsetzen
nur so können wir abseits von
Stichproben überhaupt auf die Menschen
zugehen ja die zögern oder bisher
kategorisch auch die Impfung abgelehnt
haben und ohne ein solches Register
bleibt den Fälschern und Betrügern
weiterhin Tür und Tor geöffnet neben der
praktischen Umsetzung einer möglichen
corona-pflicht hätte ich an solches
Register hätte ein solches Register noch
weitere zahlreiche Vorteile
wir sind aktuell nicht einmal in der
Lage unsere Impfquote korrekt und genau
zu erfassen und müssen uns dabei auf
Evaluation von Impfstoffen auf Daten aus
anderen Ländern verlassen das ist für
mich persönlich ein Trauerspiel wir
brauchen bessere Daten wir brauchen ein
zentrales im Register wie es ist in
Dänemark in Schweden oder in Österreich
bereits vorhanden ist
selbst in Italien ist man jetzt am
Aufbau so eines Registers weil es
einfach so wertvolle Daten liefern kann
auch Deutschland kann ein Modell
umsetzen schnell und vor allem unter
Berücksichtigung des Datenschutzes dem
bedenken Sie auch dabei genaue
Informationen zur Impfung bedeuten ein
genaueres Bild hinsichtlich der
Impfstoffe zu gewinnen und das schafft
absolute Transparenz und davon
profitieren wir alle denn wir gewinnen
ihr durch breite Erkenntnisse die uns
eine stärkere Kontrolle der Produzenten
ermöglichen und unsere Abhängigkeit von
Daten aus anderen Ländern reduzieren
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass wir es
gemeinsam auch ohne eine Impfpflicht
durch die Pandemie schaffen in dieser
Lage ist es aber wohl unser letztes
Mittel um nicht in der nächsten Welle
wieder vor einer unmöglichen Situation
zu stehen die erneut Einschränkungen des
öffentlichen Lebens erforderlich macht
mit all den resultierenden negativen
Folgen
aber ohne die Grundlage wie beschrieben
wird eine Impfpflicht schon dann ein
Problem weil wir beim
einleitungseinladungsmanagement schon
Probleme haben lassen Sie uns die Chance
nicht versäumen die Evaluation von
Impfstoffen künftig unabhängig und
schnell hier in Deutschland ohne
Rückgriff auf fremde Datensätze
durchführen zu können vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin stammt Fiebig
als nächster Redner erhält das Wort der
Abgeordnete Erwin Rödel für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren die unter der
Delta Variante begonnene Impfpflicht
oder Diskussion über Impfpflicht denke
ich muss unter omecon neu bewertet
werden weil Omegon die Spielregeln
verändert hat und die
Vorsitzende des Deutschen Ethikrates hat
vor einigen Wochen erklärt da das Virus
seine Strategien ändert dürfen wir auch
unsere Meinung ändern wie wir dem Virus
begegnen und zu Beginn der Pandemie war
ich der Meinung es gibt keine
Impfpflicht in Deutschland das haben wir
den Menschen versprochen unter Delta
habe ich meine Meinung geändert und
bin dazu übergegangen für eine
Impfpflicht zu werben
omecon lässt mich diese Welt eine ganz
wesentlich differenzierter sehen
gebustert ist man bei omecon immer gut
geschützt auch vor schweren Verläufen
und trotzdem gibt es sehr schnell sehr
viele Infektionen vielleicht sogar so
schnell dass eine Impfpflicht nicht
greifen wird zum Glück sind die Verläufe
bei omecon etwas milder was sich auch
darin zeigt dass wir eine sehr niedrige
hospitalisierungsrate haben gleichzeitig
haben wir erste Medikamente die schwere
Verläufe verhindern können wenn wir
zudem die gegenwärtige impf- und
boosterkampagne konsequent fortführen
dann sehe ich durchaus eine Chance aus
der Pandemie heraus in eine Phase der
Endemie zu treten die dann einen Weg
zurück in die Normalität der wird es
gibt also sehr viel Grund zur Zuversicht
für
omecon kommt die Impfpflicht in jedem
Fall zu spät für die Endemie wäre sie
vermutlich unnötig sollte es aber aus
heutiger Sicht wieder Erwarten zu einer
Verschärfung der Situation kommen dann
sollte man anstelle einer allgemeinen
Impfpflicht überlegen die
einrichtungsbezogenen impfpflichten
schrittweise zu erweitern etwa auf
polizei und Sicherheitskräfte kritische
Infrastruktur Schulen Kita sowie
vulnerable Altersgruppen meine Damen und
Herren aktuell sehen wir die Probleme
die die Impfpflicht in der Pflege
für uns bringt der Lackmus-Test wird
sein ob es hier konsequent
Beschäftigungsverbote für ungeimpfte in
der Pflege ab dem 15 März geben wird
oder ob auch hier Omicron die Welt
verändert und uns zur anderen
Entscheidungen bringt das sollte unsere
Debatte in den nächsten Wochen Monaten
begleiten für Befürworter einer Algen
meinen Impfpflicht müssen
erklären für wen die Impfpflicht wie
lange gelten soll
wie wird sie umgesetzt kontrolliert und
geahndet und wie wird parallel dazu ein
impfregister aufgebaut denn ohne ein
zentrales im Register ist nach meiner
Überzeugung die Einführung einer
allgemeinen Impfpflicht zum Scheitern
verurteilt wir haben
derzeit große Schwierigkeiten
unsere Regeln die wir beschließen auch
tatsächlich umzusetzen das sieht man
auch bei der kontaktnachverfolgung durch
den ÖGD und deshalb müssen wir den
Blindflug in datennebel beenden und
deshalb dringend unsere Hausaufgaben
machen und ein impfregister in
Verbindung mit einer weiteren
Digitalisierung und Vernetzung unseres
Gesundheitssystems auf den Weg bringen
vielen Dank
Erwin rüttel war das für die
Unionsfraktion auf ihn folgt jetzt
Cordula Schulz Asche für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen hier im Deutschen Bundestag in
dieser vereinbarten Debatte zur
Impfpflicht gegen saaskovic
das ist erst einmal nur eine
orientierungsdebatte entschieden du dir
heute noch
nichts frau Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren Herr Kollege Rudel ich möchte
Ihnen ausdrücklich meinen Respekt
aussprechen auch wenn ich Ihre Meinung
nicht Teile aber dass sie sich nicht an
der offensichtlich von der Fraktion
vorgegebenen Haltung beteiligen auf die
Regierung einzuschlagen sondern
offensichtlich mit einer eigenen Meinung
hier reingegangen sind dafür möchte ich
herzliches Danke sagen
die corona-pandemie hat in den letzten
zwei Jahren meine Damen und Herren alle
unser aller Leben verändert unsere
Freiheiten eingeschränkt die Kontakte zu
Freunden zu Angehörigen eingeschränkt
und wir wünschen uns alle
dass es endlich wieder möglichst ein
Leben ohne Pandemie gibt und dies nicht
ist nicht nur ein Wunsch hier bei uns
sondern ein Wunsch weltweit
glücklicherweise haben wir unerwartet
schnell und mit verschiedenen
Impfstoffen die Möglichkeit erhalten die
Ausbreitung des Virus einzudämmen
besonders gefährdete Gruppen zu schützen
also als Gesellschaft auch solidarisch
zu sein und uns selbst zu schützen
und dieser Schutz ist umso höher je
höher die Impfquote ist und deshalb
wollen wir möglichst alle Menschen die
von der Ständigen Impfkommission für die
Impfung empfohlen werden auch impfen
warum brauchen wir eine hohe Impfquote
zwei Drittel der Menschen die bei uns
auf den Intensivstationen liegen sind
ungeimpft das Personal auf diesen
Stationen das Personal in Krankenhäusern
das Personal in Einrichtungen der
Behindertenhilfe aber auch in
Pflegeheimen
alle stehen nicht nur seit Beginn dieser
Pandemie unter einem enormen
Arbeitsdruck sondern sie setzen sich
regelmäßig auch selber einem hohen
Risiko aus und deswegen sagen wir hier
nicht nur Danke sondern wir versuchen
auch diese Gruppen zu schützen und ihnen
die Möglichkeit zu geben diese Pandemie
zu überstehen
und
die Menschen mit denen sie arbeiten
ältere Menschen kranke Menschen auch
diese Menschen haben es verdient dass
wir für ihren Schutz sorgen sie sind
haben Vorerkrankungen sie sind oft in
einem hohen Alter sie leiden unter der
Einsamkeit durch Isolation manchmal aus
Angst infiziert zu werden und deswegen
haben wir doch als Gesellschaft hier
eine Verpflichtung gerade auch diese
Gruppen zu schützen vor Infektionen
gerade auch vor 19 denn wir wissen wie
gefährlich dies für ältere Menschen ist
und es gibt Menschen mit schweren
Erkrankungen die derzeit kaum Zugang zum
Gesundheitssystem haben weil ihre
Behandlungen verschoben werden müssen
die wirklich dringend Therapie bräuchten
ich nenne hier nur Krebspatienten aber
eben auch schwere Unfälle für diese
Menschen brauchen wir Kapazitäten auf
den Intensivstationen um vernünftige
Arbeit im Gesundheitswesen leisten zu
können und deswegen meine Damen und
Herren fordern wir setzen wir uns dafür
ein dass zu erhöhen nicht nur um das die
Überlastung des Gesundheitswesens zu
vermeiden sondern um das Leid dieser
Menschen zu vermeiden und zwar jedes
einzelnen Menschen durch die Impfung ist
es uns möglich dieses zu tun und
deswegen sollten wir diese Chance auch
nutzen natürlich ist es so dass die der
eine wie immer geartete Impfpflicht eine
Verpflichtung zur Impfung ein Eingriff
in die Schutzrechte der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ist und deswegen muss man sehr
genau und sehr präzise und sehr
sorgfältig prüfen mit welchen Maßnahmen
tatsächlich das Ziel erreicht werden
kann möglichst viele Menschen zu impfen
und deswegen muss es einen mildesmittel
sein und ich finde dass wir mit dem
Vorschlag mit dem Antrag der hier in der
Erarbeitung ist der vorsieht zwei Sachen
auf einem guten Weg sind das erste ist
eine verpflichtende individuelle
Impfberatung für alle
und der zweite ein Impfpflicht nach
einer Nachweispflicht für Menschen über
50 Jahren aufgrund ihrer hohen ihren
ihres hohen Risikos warum spreche ich
nicht für eine Impfpflicht allgemein
Impfpflicht ab 18 weil ich es nach wie
vor für ein großes Problem halte dass
wir die Bedenken aus der kosmostudie
nämlich dass es erhebliche
Informationsdefizite gibt nach wie vor
zu Corona mit denen der verbundenen
Risiken und zu den Impfstoffen immer
verschärft von den Leuten hier am
rechten Rand dass wir tatsächlich hier
zu einer guten Beratung kommen müssen um
diese Menschen zu überzeugen und wir
brauchen gute endlich gute
Kommunikationskampagnen für die
allgemeine Bevölkerung und für einzelne
Zielgruppen aufsuchende impfangebote wir
können von anderen Ländern lernen auch
von der Hansestadt Bremen das sollten
Sie bitte zum Schluss Frau Kollegin das
sollten wir tun und das gilt eben und in
dem Sinne bitte ich sie alle arbeiten
sie an den verschiedenen Anträgen die ja
vorliegen mit am bin an dem an die nicht
gerade vorgestellt habe herzlichen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Debatte ist ja wirklich wichtig und wir
versuchen sie schon nicht zu unter nicht
zu
uns vielleicht behalten sie auch noch so
lange alle ihre Masken auf bis sie dran
sind ich möchte Sie nur darauf hinweisen
dass Sie bitte sich auch ein bisschen an
die Zeit halten wir geben Ihnen ja schon
immer einige Minuten aber es ist schade
wenn wir sie unterbrechen müssen als
nächstes erhält das Wort für die
afd-fraktion gereon Bollmann für seine
erste Rede im Deutschen Bundestag Herr
Abgeordnete auch sie werden die letzten
zwei Minuten dann auf den Uhren sehen
können so dass sie sich ein bisschen
daran orientieren bitte bitteschön frau
Präsidentin vielen Dank meine Damen und
Herren liebe Zuschauer auf der Tribüne
und zu Hause vor dem Bildschirm
mit Ihrer Erlaubnis frau Präsidentin
beginne ich mit einem Zitat
eine Impfpflicht macht bei saßkow 2 so
wenig sind wie bei einer Grippe wenn die
Impfung gut wirkt wird sie auch
freiwillig gemacht dann ist keine
Impfpflicht nötig wenn Sie viele
Nebenwirkungen hat oder nicht so gut
wirkt verbietet sich Impfpflicht daher
nie sinnvoll
nun das stammt von unserem
Gesundheitsminister
Herr Lauterbach gerade nicht mehr an
seinem Platz und seine Kollegen haben
uns auch im letzten Herbst versprochen
Verzeihung wenn ich ihn zu nahe getreten
bin ich habe auf die Regierungsbank
geguckt Herr Lauterbach dann ist es sehr
schön dass Sie da sind aber sie haben
uns jedenfalls im letzten Herbst
versprochen es werde keine Impfpflicht
geben das ist nun mal so das ist doch
der klassische Fall eines gebrochenen
Wahlversprechens
nein sagen sie wir haben ja neue
Erkenntnisse nun die haben sie eben
gerade nicht es ist auch ein alter Hut
dass sie die bisher Erreichte Quote
nicht für ausreichend unterhalten mit
ihrer Politik treiben Sie unser
Gesundheitssystem in den Ruinen
während eine Infektion mit Omicron meist
harmlos verläuft leidet das
Gesundheitswesen an der bereits von
ihnen verordneten Impfpflicht kommen Sie
doch einmal in der Wirklichkeit an die
vielen Menschen in der Pflege und im
Gesundheitswesen wollen sich nicht
impfen lassen und werden ihrem Beruf
spätestens im Mitte März den Rücken
kehren schauen Sie doch einmal ins
Ausland Dänemark England und Irland
werden sämtliche Maßnahmen aufgehoben
auch Spanien wird öffnen und Deutschland
was ist nur mit uns los fast überall
werden die Maßnahmen aufgehoben bei uns
im Norden Fragen die Leute sich schon
happy in Berlin irgendwie
Herr Bundeskanzler schön dass sie wieder
da sind
sie und ihre Regierung haben mit medial
unterstütztem Druck und falschem
Freiheitsversprechen gerade den
schwächsten die Impfung aufgezwungen die
Verweigerer werden ausgegrenzt Menschen
die aus der breiten Mitte des Volkes von
Jung bis Alt Arbeiter Handwerker Rentner
alle werden von ihnen als
Verfassungsfeinde verleumdet weil sie
Freiheit statt Zwang fordern waren sie
mal auf einem motorspaziergang wohl
nicht da sind Menschen für Demokratie
und für Freiheit unterwegs eine Freiheit
die sie ihnen entziehen
sie wollen angeblich viele vor einem
schweren Krankheitsverlauf schützen aber
dafür nehmen sie sogar Todesfälle einige
billigend in Kauf warum liefert das RKI
hierzu bis heute keine validen Zahlen
warum gibt es in anderen Ländern
detailliertes Statistiken zu den vielen
Impfnebenwirkungen und hier muss der
Land Deutschland nicht warum ist man
hierzu nicht in der Lage warum kann man
positive Tests nicht von Infektionen
warum nicht mit oder an Corona
verstorbene unterscheiden
und lassen sie endlich unsere Kinder aus
ihrem erbarmungslosen Griff und ihre
täglich befeuerten Impfkampagne mit
damit treiben sie Zwist in unsere
Familien und bringen viele Jugendliche
gegen ihre Eltern auf Herr Abgeordneter
kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss
bei Herrn Ali waren sie ja er war ihre
Vorgängerin vorhin nicht so ungenehmigt
da hat auch die erste Rede gehabt aber
ich komme zum Schluss diese Politik
wollen nicht mit ihnen nicht über die
Redezeit und wann sie reden und wann
nicht kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss
die wollen wir nicht und die lehnen wir
Wehen und ab vielen Dank
als nächstes erhält das Wort für die
FDP-Fraktion die Abgeordnete Linda
Teuteberg
auch Linda Teuteberg ist wie viele ihrer
Fraktion gegen eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
impfen ist eine Errungenschaft und ein
Segen es ist ein Segen das in unserem
Land allen Menschen die sich impfen
lassen wollen so schnell ein wirksamer
Impfstoff zur Verfügung steht das ist
auch Zeichen der Leistungsfähigkeit
eines Gemeinwesens in dem Wissenschaft
und unternehmerische Betätigung viel
Freiheit und Respekt bekommen
und zugleich ist auch die
Selbstbestimmung erwachsener Menschen
über Eingriffe in ihren Körper in ihre
körperliche Unversehrtheit Kennzeichen
dieses Liberalen Gemeinwesens
und das schätzen auch viele geimpfte
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
trotz ist das Gegenteil von
Unabhängigkeit hat Friedrich Nietzsche
einmal gesagt und es lohnt sich darüber
nachzudenken diese wichtige Debatte über
eine mögliche allgemeine
corona-impflicht und das Impfen die
taugt weder dafür sich selbstgefällig
als Widerstandskämpfer zu stilisieren
und wirkliche Diktaturen zu verharmlosen
sie taugt auf der anderen Seite auch
nicht dafür ein Exempel zu statuieren
und es bestimmten Bevölkerungsgruppen
mal zu zeigen und ein Signal zu setzen
sowohl
sowohl impfangst als auch Wut darüber
sind schlechte Ratgeber und ich möchte
gerne ganz bewusst aufgreifen was für
Kollegen Behrens gesagt hat und es noch
weiterführen
Zumutungen und Gegner in dieser Pandemie
ist das Virus es ist nicht der Mitmensch
und nicht unser politisches System liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und
meine Zweifel allerdings an einer
allgemeinen Impfpflicht die sind da und
sie sind eher noch gewachsen sie beruhen
einerseits auf Zweifeln an der
verfassungsrechtlichen
Verhältnismäßigkeit zum anderen an
Fragen der praktischen Umsetzbarkeit und
Durchsetzbarkeit die übrigens bei Lichte
besehen auch die Verhältnismäßigkeit
beeinflusst weil sie nämlich bestimmt
wie wirksam eine Impfpflicht tatsächlich
überhaupt sein kann und bei der Frage
von politischen Vertrauensschaden und
gesellschaftlichen Verwerfungen dadurch
die Nebenwirkungen wie seine Kollegin
gerade auch schon ausgedrückt hat eine
allgemein Impfpflicht die sind schon
ziemlich ersichtlich ihr Nutzen ist
immer fraglicher
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
müssen uns glaube ich hier überhaupt
nicht die guten Absichten absprechen
sondern über den Weg streiten es wäre
auch die falsche alternative einer
allgemeinen Impfpflicht nichts tun
entgegenzustellen ich habe hier nicht
die Zeit auf alles einzugehen ich sag
mal ein paar Anregungen Politik aufgrund
aktueller und aussagekräftiger zahlen
statt Politik mitzahlen wäre ein Ansatz
testkapazitäten auszuweiten und immer
rechtzeitig vorzuhalten als Teil
vorausschauender Politik und vieles mehr
die Pandemie ist eine Prüfung eine
Prüfung für unsere Fähigkeit auch mit
der Ungewissheit und Komplexität der
Situation und einer modernen
Gesellschaft umzugehen eine Prüfung auf
unsere Fähigkeit und Bereitschaft zu
Differenzierung und unsere Fähigkeit und
Bereitschaft nachvollziehbar damit
umzugehen was wir wissen und was wir
nicht wissen
lassen sie uns trotz der Kräfte und
nervenzehrenden Zumutungen dieser
Pandemie die Fassung bewahren und unsere
Verfassung achten lassen sie uns der
Versuchung widerstehen in einfache
binäre Logiken von Schwarz und Weiß Gut
und Böse und manchem anderen zu
verfallen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
es ist schick geworden verächtlich über
Freiheit und Grundrechte zu reden und
Freiheitsgrundrechte und
Verhältnismäßigkeit die sind nicht
vulgär die sind nicht orthodox die sind
auch nicht formalistisch die sind
systemrelevant für unsere freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung und
einige einige Redebeiträge auf meines
Vorredners eben und manch andere zeigen
doch gerade in dieser Zeit dürfen wir
die Grundrechte nicht mit den Vertretern
des abstrusen allein lassen auch das ist
ein Grund des Antrages an dem ich mit
anderen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
arbeitet die sollen Ernstes schwieriges
Thema wie eine allgemeine schlecht gegen
Corona da geht es nicht um
Gesichtswahrung von PolitikerInnen im
Hinblick auf versprechen oder
Ankündigungen es geht um etwas
Grundsätzliches über den Tag hinaus um
die Wahrung des Gesichts nicht von
Politikern sondern unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen Grundordnung auf das wir
unser Land wiedererkennen nach der
Pandemie als offene Gesellschaft zum
Schluss als liberale Demokratie und als
freiheitlicher Rechtsstaat lassen Sie
uns deshalb genau zeigen es gibt einen
Unterschied zwischen einer
entschlossenen klugenpandemiebekämpfung
einerseits und einer schleichenden
Gewöhnung an einen übermaßstaatlicher
Eingriffe andererseits vielen Dank
Linda Teuteberg war das für die
FDP-Fraktion nächster Redner ist
Johannes Huber er war noch bis Ende des
Jahres Mitglied der afd-fraktion ist
dann ausgetreten und damit jetzt
fraktionslos hat auch so zwei Minuten
Redezeit Präsident sehr geehrte
Abgeordnete diejenigen die an den
allgemeinen Impfzwang einführen wollen
diejenigen müssen vollständig beweisen
warum dies geeignet erforderlich und
angemessen sein soll sie behaupten nur
durch die Pandemie ließen sich die nur
durch den Impfzwang ließen sich die
Pandemie beenden und das normale Leben
zurückgewinnen zur Wahrheit gehört aber
dass ein normales Leben seit zwei Jahren
von den Bundes- und Landesregierungen
doch überzogene Maßnahmen verhindert
wurde alle von der EU eingekauften und
von der Bundesregierung bestellten covit
Impfstoffe sind einem Ziel die Pandemie
zu beenden krachen gescheitert weder
können die Impfstoffe eine Infektion
verhindern noch die Ansteckung anderer
Personen das Bundesland Bremen mit der
Höch Impfquote hat paradoxerweise auch
die höchste hospitalisierungsrate damit
ist ihr Argument die Impfstoffe würden
vor einem schweren Verlauf schützen auch
eindeutig widerlegt es ist daher auf
keinen Fall angemessen die überragenden
Grundrechte der Würde des Menschen und
der körperlichen Unversehrtheit in Bezug
auf die ungeeigneten Impfstoffe
auszusetzen die gute Nachricht
angesichts der raschen viruswandlungen
in Richtung omikronartiger Varianten mit
hoher Infektiosität bei geringerer
Gefährlichkeit ist ein Impfzwang auch
nicht erforderlich einen Zwang für
Impfstoffe die immer schneller veralten
hätte sich auch Franz Kafka nicht
groteska ausdenken können da die in
Deutschland verfügbaren Impfstoffe
nämlich gegen die derzeitige
omegonvariante wie nicht wirksam sind
und zudem ein Impfzwang die aktuelle
omegonwelle nicht mehr erreicht schaffen
sie den Faktor ein Gesetz für neue
Varianten und neue Impfstoffe mit
anderen Worten sie beschließen einen
Impfzwang für ein Virus dass man noch
nicht kennt und für einen Impfstoff
den man noch nicht hat geschweige denn
dass man etwas über das zu erwartende
Risiko nutzenverhältnis weiß weil der
neue Impfstoff noch gar nicht für den im
Herbst der warteten neuen Virus
entwickelt worden sein kann Liebe
Abgeordnete so etwas ist nicht
zustimmungsfähig sondern
verfassungswidrig ich bedanke mich daher
herzlich bei allen die sich für die
freie Selbstbestimmung entscheiden
vielen Dank
als nächstes erhält das Wort für die
SPD-Fraktion der Abgeordnete hellgelind
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen im Godesberger Programm findet
sich die schöne Formulierung in den
Grundwerten des Sozialismus Freiheit und
Gerechtigkeit Bedingungen einander ich
glaube wir müssen reden über den
Zusammenhang von Freiheit und
Gerechtigkeit und wir müssen reden über
Demokratie und überprävention und ich
empfehle dass wir eine Art von Reframing
vornehmen und das dicht weil das so
modisch ist sondern weil es
gesellschaftspolitisch geboten ist es
geht hier nicht nur um individuelle
Freiheit und medizinische Maßnahmen
sondern es geht um deutlich mehr und ich
beginne dabei weil ich von Demokratie
reden möchte mit den Anwürfen der
Opposition besonders
ärgerlich aber auch amüsant finde ich
die wollte immer sich an Olaf Scholz zu
wenden und den Satz zu zitieren wer
Führung bestellte bekommt sie und das zu
kritisieren im alle 2022 stelle ich mir
und ich glaube viele in diesem Plenum
Führung so vor dass ein Bundeskanzler
das Parlament achtet und respektiert und
seine Bevölkerung würdigt
es ist besonders widersprüchlich wenn
sie dann von autoritären Maßnahmen
sprechen was denn nun autoritär oder zu
wenig Führung das zeigt dass sie viel zu
bieten haben hinsichtlich lamentieren
lavieren kritisieren konkretisieren habe
ich nicht erlebt und nicht gespürt
das was wir aber gerade brauchen dafür
ist dies der richtige Ort ist Debatte
mein achte auf die Ausführung des
Bundespräsidenten der gerade solche
Foren eröffnet hat und er macht das und
eröffnete das mit den Worten
Impfpflicht bedeutet
Debatte und Debatte über die Impfpflicht
und genau das tun wir hier und es ist
richtig dass wir das tun
zum zweiten
wird ja immer darauf verwiesen und
einige die auch mal eine Regierung waren
leiden da an Amnesie dass sie auch mal
Teil dieser Regierung waren dass man ja
dass man ja sie ausgeschlossen hätte und
das stimmt und das ist auch ein
ernsthafter Punkt der Vertrauen Kosten
kann aber es ist schlicht unwahr und
eine Lüge und nahezu schon
verschwörungstheoretisch irgendwie zu
insinuieren dass wir eine bewusste
Täuschung oder Lüge gewesen diese
Aussage erfolgte unter konkreten
Bedingungen und manche ich erinnere mich
genau sagten auch sie können zu dem
Zeitpunkt sich nicht dazu entscheiden
und verhalten weil nicht für alle ein
impfgebot gemacht werden kann
gucken wir mal auf die Ergebnisse des
Ethikrates als Analogie November
2020 auch noch mal 2021 im Februar
schloss er eine Impfpflicht aus jetzt
ist mehrheitlich die Positionierung
geändert worden und das auf eine sehr
nachvollziehbare gut begründete Weise
heißt das wir haben kein Vertrauen mehr
in den edekraten nein das heißt dass man
Entscheidungen überdenkt und korrigiert
in der freien Wirtschaft in der
Gesellschaft heißt das Fehlerkultur
wollen wir alte Rituale pflegen oder
haben wir das Verständnis eines modernen
Parlaments und einer modernen Regierung
die sich selbstkritisch betrachtet und
raus Schlussfolgerung zieht ich empfehle
letzteres und dann kommen wir zu dem
Punkt der Freiheit und es ist einfach
ein vulgäres Verständnis von Freiheit
immer zu denken Freiheit ist nur rein
individuelle Unversehrtheit und leider
das muss ich auch mal kritisch sagen
sind es oft diejenigen die sich
besonders laut äußern und die dann auch
Grenzen überschreiten auf Demos nicht
alle wohlgemerkt aber einzelne die die
Privilegien und Vorteile der Freiheit
immer genossen haben und jetzt wo sie
selbst Einschränkung Treffen in Form
etwa einer Impfpflicht sehr laut werden
sie vergessen aber dabei dass die
Freiheit endet bei der Freiheit des
anderen und dass die Gesellschaft die
Bedingung unserer Freiheit ist wir
sollten und das ist mein petitum unsere
Politik nicht Angst getrieben ausrichten
an den Sorgen und der Kritik der nicht
geimpften sondern mal ein Blick werfen
auf die Freiheit all derer die geimpft
sind die freiwillig agiert haben die in
Krankenhäusern arbeiten und die
tatsächlich auch eine Freiheit haben und
dies ist die Mehrheit derjenige der
aufgrund von Corona oder auch diejenige
im Krankenhaus ist die braucht für das
Erfahren ihrer Freiheit ein
funktionierendes Gesundheitssystem
sollte Maßgabe unseres Handelns sein auf
dieser Basis glaube ich diskutieren wir
Mitführung vernünftig und demokratisch
hey gelinte war das für die SPD-Fraktion
in dieser Debatte vielen Dank ab dem 14
Februar soll dann im Plenum über die
Anträge diskutiert werden und dann einen
Monat später das ist dann die
darauffolgende Sitzungswoche wäre es
dann möglich auch darüber abzustimmen
Nina Wacken jetzt für die Unionsfraktion
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ziemlich zwei Jahre
und mit der Pandemie über neun Millionen
Menschen mindestens haben sich infiziert
gut 160.000 Menschen hat die Krankheit
so schwer getroffen dass sie auf den
Intensivstationen behandelt werden
mussten auch aktuell sind es hunderte
die ganz überwiegend dem Tod näher sind
als dem Leben bis heute sind rund
117.000 Personen aufgrund von covid 19
verstorben auch wenn die
Realitätsverweigerer und corona-leugner
insbesondere von Rechtsaußen das
krakehlend und verharmlosend in Abrede
stellen in dieser Zeit hat der Staat
Maßnahmen ergriffen und Regeln
geschaffen die in ganz erheblichem Maße
Freiheitsrechte in einer Art und Weise
einschränken wie viele es nicht für
möglich gehalten hätten alte und junge
haben darunter gelitten und leiden
darunter wir haben den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern den Vereinen den Unternehmen und
den Verwaltungen im Sinne des Schutzes
der Gesundheit sehr viel zugemutet und
wir muten Ihnen weiterhin sehr viel zu
und dann wie durch ein Wunder inmitten
der Scherben des ersten lockdowns öffnet
sich eine Perspektive für unser Land und
für die ganze Welt schneller als dies
noch die größten Optimisten unter den
Wissenschaftlern für möglich gehalten
hätten gibt es Impfstoffe die
nachweislich helfen die die
Wahrscheinlichkeit einer Infektion
reduzieren und wenn sie einem dann doch
ereilt den Verlauf ganz erheblich
mildern und einer dieser Impfstoffe
wurde bei uns hier in Deutschland
entwickeln und man muss kein besonderer
Patriot sein um es großartig zu halten
dass wir hier mit uns und anderen helfen
können meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
und seitdem liegt es an zwei Faktoren ob
wir diese Pandemie besiegen und wieder
zur Normalität zurückkehren können oder
eben nicht erstens an der Frage wie
schnell Impfstoff hergestellt beschafft
und zu den Menschen gebracht werden kann
und zweitens an der Zahl der Menschen
die sich auch tatsächlich impfen lassen
aber offenkundig hat die neue
Bundesregierung nichts aus dem letzten
Winter gelernt sie läutet nicht etwa die
Alarmglocke laut damit es alle verstehen
und sich endlich impfen lassen sondern
sie trifft stattdessen die Feststellung
dass keine epidemische Lage von
nationaler Tragweite mehr gegeben ist
gibt sozusagen Entwarnung
die ampelparteien haben aus einem falsch
verstandenen Freiheitsgedanken heraus
möglicherweise auch wegen fehlenden
Mutes das Ruder genau in die falsche
Richtung gerissen und es ist wertvolle
Zeit für unser ins Land gegangen mit
Omegon hat sich die Lage geändert aber
das bedeutet doch nicht dass die
Pandemie tatsächlich vorbei ist liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Gegenteil
wir müssen vorbereitet sein auf den
Herbst lassen Sie sich nicht wieder
durch Unentschlossenheit treiben sondern
kommen sie vor die Lage wir haben nach
wie vor eine Impfquote die nicht
ausreichend ist und darüber gibt es ja
auch unter den vernünftigen in diesen
Parlament keine abweichenden
Auffassungen und daher rufe ich Ihnen zu
handeln sie endlich bereiten Sie das
Land vor einzelne Regierungsmitglieder
haben sich für eine Impfpflicht
ausgesprochen das reicht aber nicht
legen Sie ein Gesetz vor das regelt wann
eine Impfpflicht eingeführt werden mehr
soll für wen sie gilt welche
Pflichtimpfungen darunter gefasst werden
und wie Verstöße geahndet werden und
sorgen Sie für die Möglichkeit einer
Nachvollziehbarkeit der Impfungen anhand
eines impfregisters und wenn Sie all das
nicht wollen dann sagen Sie hier und
heute wie sie sonst die Impfquote
erhöhen und die Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystems vermeiden wollen wir
als Union bleiben dabei Ihnen als
konstruktive
Opposition zur Seite zu stehen aber sie
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von SPD
Grünen und FDP sie haben die Mehrheit
hier im Bundestag und sie haben die
Verantwortung herzlichen Dank
war das für die Unionsfraktion nächster
Redner ist nun Helge Limburg von Bündnis
90 Dingen Grünen
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Frau Kollegin
Wacken zu der Rede vielleicht nur eins
wenn sie und auch Ihre Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Unionsfraktion im Einsatz
mal wieder betonen dass sie eine
konstruktive
Opposition sein wollen und im nächsten
Moment dann aber klar machen die
Einladung zur Mitarbeit zu inhaltlichen
Mitarbeit an den gruppenanträgen die
schlagen wir in jedem Einzelfall aus und
werden auch keinen eigenen Vorschlag
vorliegen dann fehlt mir ein bisschen
der Glaube an den ersten Satz vorbei
ich habe ihn sehr gut zugehört Händler
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
heute zu Recht oft genug betont worden
impfen hilft impfen hilft sich selbst
und anderen und in der Tat halte ich es
die ganz große Märkten in diesem Hause
für sehr vernünftig sich impfen zu
lassen aber darauf hat der Kollege
Kubicki zu Recht hingewiesen die
freiheits-grundrechte unseres
Grundgesetzes schützen auch die
Unvernunft sie schützen gerade auch das
individuelle recht etwas anderes zu
machen als das was sozial von der
Mehrheit erwünscht ist genau das ist das
Wesen der Freiheit und
Minderheitenrechte eine allgemeine
eine allgemeine mit Strafen bewährte
Pflicht sich impfen zu lassen wäre
natürlich ein gewichtiger Eingriff in
diese Grundrechte die Pflicht eine
Substanz in seinem Körper aufzunehmen
ist natürlich ein Eingriff und sie
müsste gut begründet sein ja manchmal
das Gefühl dass die allgemeine
Impfpflicht so als die eine große
reinigende Maßnahme wahrgenommen wird
die unserer Gesellschaft dann sozusagen
diese schrecklichen Jahre endlich
beendet aber liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich glaube nicht dass das so
einfach ist unser einfach der Fall sein
wird ich glaube die Folgen und die
Umsetzung Schwierigkeiten das haben
viele schon zurecht betont wären
gewaltig und deswegen auch nicht trivial
dass wir klar definieren welches Ziel
eigentlich verfolgt werden soll
der Schutz der individuellen Gesundheit
die Tatsache dass impfen uns ein in die
uns als jeder einzelne schützt reicht
aus meiner Sicht jedenfalls nicht aus
weil ich habe es eingangs gesagt der
demokratische Rechtsstaat der freie
demokratische Rechtsstaat eben nicht als
paternalistischer Staat die Menschen
quasi vor sich selber schützen darf
es bleiben es bleibt der Schutz der
Freiheitsrechte anderer ist die Kollegin
heiligen klar und andere zu Recht darauf
eingegangen natürlich ein Überlastung
des Gesundheitssystems schränkt anderen
ihrer Freiheit ein natürlich die
Situation in Kitas und Schulen mit immer
wiederkehrenden Quarantäne Schließungen
Einschränkungen von freizeitaktivieren
ähnliches schränkt andere
Freiheitsrechte ein insofern kann die
alternativ könnte die Alternative zu
einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht nicht sein
einfach die bisherigen Maßnahmen
weiterlaufen lassen und die Frage muss
schon sein ob eine Impfpflicht
tatsächlich das mildeste Mittel ist was
wir gegenwärtig zur Verfügung haben
wenn wir doch zum Beispiel wissen dass
einige Menschen ungeimpft sind weil sie
auf den Tod oder proteinimpfstoff warten
und der jetzt gerade kommt warum
konzentrieren wir uns dann nicht darauf
diesen ganz gezielt dorthin zu bringen
wo die Impfquoten noch sehr niedrig sind
sehen Sie wie es Rheinland-Pfalz
wenn wir wissen dass es Menschen gibt
die große Ängste um ihre Gesundheit
haben etwa vor Wehen Thrombosen und
ähnlichem warum bieten wir da nicht auch
wenn es exotisch klingt eine sehr
engmaschige medizinische Betreuung
gegebenenfalls stationär nach einer
Impfung an um auch diesen Ängsten zu
begegnen und schließlich liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen warum versuchen
wir es nicht zunächst mit einer
allgemeinen im Beratungspflicht aber
ohne das bereits quasi der virtuelle
Bußgeldbescheid über dem Gespräch hängt
sondern eine offene vertrauensvolle
Impfberatung das alles ist weiter in
mühevoll und mein Dank geht natürlich
allen beteiligt seine bisherigen
Impfkampagne auf allen Ebenen riesigen
Dank und Anerkennung aber seien wir
ehrlich eine allgemeine Impfpflicht wäre
eben auch sehr sehr mühevoll es ist zu
Recht angesprochen worden dass die
Durchsetzung einer Impfpflicht verbunden
mit Bußgeldbescheiden auf die dann Haft
zwar ausdrücklich nicht folgen soll aber
da muss ja trotzdem auf andere Weise der
Bußgeldbescheid vollzogen werden gegen
der gegen den Willen der Betroffenen
auch sehr mühevoll ist wir müssen
bedenken dass es Menschen gibt die
vielleicht keine klare Diagnose haben du
darfst nicht geimpft werden aber die
unklare Diagnosen haben die sollten wir
aus meiner Sicht auf jeden Fall von
einer Impfpflicht ausnehmen müssen im
Zweifel muss der individuelle
Gesundheitsschutz gelten
manche Kampagnen gegen die Impfung ich
komme zum Schluss noch Präsidentin oder
die Kampagnen gegen die Impfung arbeiten
natürlich mit Unwahrheiten und Fake News
aber die daraus entstehen in Ängste sind
real und wir sollten uns schon überlegen
obwohl es nicht mildere Mittel einfallen
als diesen Ängsten mit Bußgeldbescheiden
zu begegnen vielen Dank
einige Abgeordnete sprechen sich für
eine Impfpflicht ab 50 Jahren aus so
auch der nächste Redner Konstantin coole
für die FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die heutige Debatte über eine
Impfpflicht gegen das Coronavirus ist
eine demokratiefrage denn unsere
Gesellschaft ist in einer schwierigen
Situation seit zwei Jahren kämpfen
Gemeinwesen und Staat gegen das Virus
und seit zwei Jahren stellen wir an
vielen Stellen fest dass der Frust und
die Enttäuschung in der Gesellschaft
immer größer wird und wir müssen hier
anerkennen und das haben einige der
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und dafür danke
ich ausdrücklich hier auch getan dass
viel von diesem Frust und viel von
dieser Enttäuschung auch mit der
mangelhaften Kommunikation der Politik
in den letzten zwei Jahren zusammenhängt
wir haben Fehler gemacht wir haben nicht
hinreichend über die eigenen Zweifel
über die eigenen Unzulänglichkeiten über
die eigenen Unsicherheiten im
Zusammenhang mit der corona-bekämpfung
gesprochen und ich wünsche mir dass die
heutige Debatte einen Beitrag dazu
leistet dass wir auch die Entfremdung
zwischen der Bevölkerung und den
staatlichen Institutionen wieder ein
Stück weit überwinden meine Damen und
Herren denn es ist ein kernwert der
Demokratie dass die Institutionen der
Demokratie auch zur Selbstkorrektur in
der Lage sind und so sehr der Respekt
vor denjenigen die bei ihrer Meinung
bleiben wollen zur heutigen Debatte dazu
gehört so sehr gehört auch der Respekt
dazu gegenüber denjenigen die ihre
Meinung angesichts einer neuen Situation
ändern wollen und auch dafür bin ich
dankbar dass das hier heute möglich ist
meine Damen und
Herren die Debatte über eine Impfpflicht
ist aber nicht nur eine demokratiefrage
sie ist auch eine Freiheitsfrage und ich
rate dazu diese Debatte auch anhand des
Maßstabs der Freiheit zu führen was wir
aber nicht zulassen dürfen ist dass
permanent so das permanent so getan wird
als sei die Impfung quasi die
Fortsetzung der Freiheitsbeschränkungen
der Pandemie die Impfung ist der Weg und
mit den Freiheitsbeschränkungen der
Pandemie endlich Schluss zu machen und
die Diskussion über eine Impfpflicht ist
eine komplizierte Angelegenheit die
anhand der Freiheit der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger gemessen werden muss und
ausgestaltet werden muss und deswegen
kommt das sehr genau und sehr präzise
auf die Verhältnismäßigkeit an und ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass eine
allgemeine impfpflichtverhältnismäßig
ist bevor wir nicht jedem die
Gelegenheit gegeben hat gegeben haben in
einem verpflichtenden Beratungsgespräch
darüber mehr zu erfahren was ihnen
umtreibt oder was sie umtreibt und
deswegen muss der erste Schritt ein
verpflichtendes Beratungsgespräch sein
ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen dass
eine impfpflichtverhältnismäßig ist bei
der alle Menschen gleich behandelt
werden natürlich macht es typischerweise
einen Unterschied wenn Menschen über 50
oder über 60 sind als wenn sie jünger
sind und natürlich ist der Gesetzgeber
dazu verpflichtet sogar wenn er eine
allgemeine abstrakte Entscheidung
treffen soll zu typisieren das macht er
an allen Stellen man kann auch nicht mit
unter 40 als Bundespräsident kandidieren
weil man typischerweise davon ausgeht
dass man über 40 reifer ist und diese
dieses andere ausführen kann also
Typisierungen sind im Gesetzgeber immer
an Heim gestellt und sollten deswegen
auch in dieser Frage eine Rolle spielen
und deswegen wünsche ich mir einen
Mittelweg zwischen der Einführung einer
allgemeinen Impfpflicht auf der einen
Seite und auf der anderen Seite der
Verhinderung einer allgemeinen
Impfpflicht ich habe für beide
Positionen Respekt ich glaube aber dass
wir uns im Vorbereitung auf den nächsten
Winter Gedanken darüber machen müssen
wie wir die Impfquote massiv noch einmal
steigern ich glaube dass das politische
Kapital um von um die nicht so um die
80% Impfquote zu gelangen zu hoch wäre
bei einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht ich
glaube aber dass eine Kombination aus
Beratungspflicht und altersbezogener
impfpflichtverhältnismäßig wäre und lade
alle auch aus der Union ein an diesen
Modell mitzuarbeiten herzlichen Dank
Konstantin coole war das für die
FDP-Fraktion und Jessica Rosenthal ist
von der SPD hat sich der Initiative von
dirke Wiese angeschlossen ebenfalls SPD
eine Impfpflicht ab 18 einzuführen
heute schon öfter gehört zwei Jahre ist
es her dass der erste corona-fall in
Deutschland aufgetreten ist morgen und
das sind 731 Tage mit denen wir jetzt in
dieser Pandemie Leben und auch das spürt
man hier das spürt man an anderen Orten
die Erschöpfung ist eben überall zu
spüren das Distanz halten die Masken die
Maßnahmen das alles kostet uns extrem
viel Kraft
731 Tage Pandemie bedeuten für eine
junge Studentin dass sie in diesem Jahr
ihren Bachelor beenden wird ohne einmal
einen Pandemie freien Unialltag erlebt
zu haben
731 Tage Pandemie heißen für ein
Grundschulkind dass es in die dritte
Klasse gekommen ist ohne einmal im
Musikunterricht gesungen oder eine
Lesenacht mitgemacht zu haben
731 Tage Pandemie hieß für eine
Auszubildende für den ab für die
Abschlussprüfung zu lernen ohne all die
Inhalte auch nur ansatzweise in der
Praxis gemacht zu haben
diese großen Einschränkungen von
Freiheit in Kauf zu nehmen war für keine
entscheidungsträgerin jemals einfach das
oberste Ziel ist bar und bleibt ist die
Allgemeinheit zu schützen in dem
kritische Infrastruktur am Laufen
gehalten wird und vor allem das
Gesundheitswesen nicht an seine
Belastungsgrenzen kommt ich freue mich
dass wir in diesen Zielen glaube ich
alle einig sind
dabei hat dieses Parlament
und damit haben sie alle
immer wieder die schwierige Abwägung
getroffen zwischen Freiheit und
Sicherheit
abwägen müssen ob der Preis für das eine
zu hoch und für das andere tragbar ist
ich möchte sie alle bitten diese
Abwägung neu zu justieren denn anders
als vor 731 Tagen sind nicht länger
kontaktbeschränkungen Schulschließungen
oder Lockdown Instrumente um das
Gesundheitswesen aber auch vulnerable
Gruppen zu schützen anders als vor zwei
Jahren haben wir dank der Wissenschaft
heute die Impfung zur Verfügung
und dabei ist klar
glasklar das auch die Impfung kein
unverwundbarkeitstrunk ist aber die
Impfung senkt das Infektionsrisiko
verringert das Risiko auch andere zu
infizieren und sie verhindert schwere
Verläufe und Todesfälle drei Impfungen
schaffen eine Grundimmunisierung drei
Impfungen sind ein geeignetes Mittel
dafür dass das Virus in demisch wird
drei Impfungen machen nach allem was wir
heute wissen möglich dass wir mit Corona
leben lernen und dieses Parlament muss
also alles Notwendige dafür tun die
impfpote auf weit über 90 Prozent zu
bringen wie sie alle oder ich sag mal
fast alle wissen und auch selbst hier
formuliert haben hätte ich mir natürlich
auch gewünscht dass wir das alles
freiwillig schaffen
aber wir müssen uns eingestehen und
davon bin ich überzeugt dass es nicht
nur auf freiwilliger Ebene machbar sein
wird eine endemische Situation zu
erreichen im Sinne der Mehrheit der
Gesellschaft im Sinne des Schutzes des
Gesundheitswesens und im Sinne möglichst
vieler Freiheiten übrigens gerade auch
für junge Menschen brauchen wir daher
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht ab 18 Jahren
denn nur wenn möglichst viele am besten
alle geimpft sind können wir die
Pandemie hinter uns lassen und ein Weg
daraus finden es ist daher aus meiner
Sicht auch nicht der richtige Weg eine
Impfpflicht lediglich auf die über
50-Jährigen zu beziehen aus meiner Sicht
ist diese Setzung willkürlich schwer
begründbar und zum anderen erreicht sie
aber das ist noch wichtiger aus meiner
Sicht nicht das Ziel einer
Grundimmunisierung aller bei erst diese
Grundimmunisierung kann ein Schutz gegen
weitere Mutationen sein und auch wohl
eine gruppenschützen die es eben nicht
nur bei den über 50-Jährigen gibt
und ich bitte Sie also alle zum Schutz
der Allgemeinheit in dieser pandemischen
Ausnahmesituation und damit sage ich
auch noch mal ganz klar mit Blick auf
den kommenden Herbst und Winter es geht
nicht um diese Welle nicht länger
vorrangig durch kontaktbeschränkungen
das Aussetzen von präsenzpflichten in
der Schule oder Online-Seminaren in Unis
die den Schutz der Allgemeinheit zu
erreichen sondern durch eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
die diejenigen zu ihrem Beitrag
verpflichtet die auch bis hierher nicht
zu einer Impfung bereit sind und da muss
man einfach sagen dass unsolidarische
Verhalten derjenigen die sich impfen
lassen können kostet die Mehrheit
einfach zu viel und deshalb bitte ich
Sie die allgemeine Impfpflicht zu
erwägen vielen Dank
für die cdu/csu-fraktion spricht jetzt
der Kollege Dr Volker Ulrich
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren Impfungen gegen das
Coronavirus haben und streitbar Leben
gerettet und schwere Verläufe reduziert
wir verdanken gesellschaftlich diesen
Impfungen viel das muss Grundlage
unserer Debatte sein die Einführung eine
allgemeine gesetzlichen impfpfliche doch
muss gut begründet sein und den
Grundsätzen der Verhältnismäßigkeit
entsprechen also geeignet erforderlich
und angemessen sein es sind viele Fragen
offen die zwingend zu beantworten sind
die eine allgemeine Impfpflicht würde
gegen die omegonwelle im Augenblick
nichts mehr nutzen es sind Fragen offen
die zwingend beantwortet werden müssen
wer eine Pflicht festlegt muss sie
zwingend konkretisieren wie soll eine
Impfpflicht Aussehen mit welchen
Impfstoffen und in welchen Abständen
gegen welche Varianten soll eine
Impfpflicht verpflichtend sein die Frage
ist auch ob das Ziel die Entlastung des
Gesundheitswesens und der Übergang einer
von einer Pandemie zu einer Endemie
tatsächlich durch die Impfungen erzielt
werden können das vor dem Hintergrund
dass im Augenblick auch mit dem Wissen
das Solidarität und Freiheit wichtige
Kategorien sind der fremdschutz nur sehr
eingeschränkt möglich ist weil im
Augenblick Menschen die sich impfen
lassen nach wie vor infektionszahl
können und andere anstecken auch wenn
das abgemeldet sind diese Fragen müssen
zwingend geklärt werden dazu brauchen
wir die Datenbasis und dazu muss auch
die Bundesregierung ihren Teil dazu
beitragen
es muss auch drüber gesprochen werden
welche Altersgruppen eine möglichen
Impfpflicht zugänglich sein sollten
gerade jüngere Menschen haben geringe
hospitalisierungsraten es wäre
möglicherweise unverhältnismäßig sie
gleich zu behandeln wie diejenigen die
typischerweise sehr viel stärker von
diesem Virus betroffen sind eine
mögliche Impfpflicht bei Damen und
Herren muss auch umsetzbar und
rechtsstaatlich durchsetzbar sein sie
kann und darf keine reine Symbolik
werden eine Impfpflicht als bloße Appell
wäre schwer zurechtfertigen klar eine
Impfpflicht ist kein Impfzwang aber es
gibt in Deutschland kein impfregister
der Impfstatus eines jeden Einzelnen ist
nicht bekannt das ist rechtsstaatlich
nicht unerheblich weil nach unseren
rechtsstaatlichen Grundsätzen muss der
Staat in einer möglichen
Bußgeldverfahren nachweisen ob jemand
nicht geimpft ist oder nicht das gelingt
aber doch wir stehen das impfregister
nur sehr schwer ohne Register wird nur
ein Verstoß übrig bleiben gegen eine
impfnachweisspflicht aber eine fehlende
impfnachweispflicht ist eben keine
fehlende Impfung deswegen von dem
Hintergrund grundsätzlicher
rechtsstaatliche Gesichtspunkte muss
auch die Frage Durchsetzbarkeit
unbedingt gelöst werden und das ist
keine Frage des Gewissens so eine Frage
des verwaltungsvollzugs und der
Gerichtsbarkeit und auch hier braucht es
eine Haltung der Bundesregierung
vor dem Hintergrund der
Verhältnismäßigkeit müssen alle Fragen
diskutiert werden wir müssen weiter für
Impfungen werben wir müssen die
Impfkampagne nach vorne bringen wir
müssen die Kapazitäten im
Gesundheitswesen ausbauen medikamentöse
Therapien sind wichtig und können zu
einer Änderung der Pandemie führen und
es muss auch weiter für Vertrauen
geworden werden die Änderung des
Gelesenen Status hat nicht vertrauen
herbeigeführt sondern ein solches eher
zerstört deswegen müssen wir
gesamtgesellschaftlich
viele Punkte uns überlegen wie wir die
Pandemie beenden können eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht muss auf alle Fälle den
Grundsätzen der Verhältnismäßigkeit
entsprechen dafür sind noch viele Fragen
zu klären lasst uns das gemeinsam
angehen
Volker Ulrich war das für die
Unionsfraktion ja noch gibt es keine
Rechtsgrundlage für eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht gegen das Coronavirus da
gibt es bisher nur erste Einschätzungen
aber das wird hier wohl auch dann Mitte
Februar nochmal Thema sein inwieweit das
überhaupt umgesetzt werden darf ob das
mit der Verfassung vereinbar ist
Stefanie Effner spricht jetzt für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich finde ja
wir führen Debatten um Argumente
abzuwägen auszutauschen und verschiedene
Aspekte einzubringen und ich glaube
niemand hier in diesem Hause kann für
sich in Anspruch nehmen dass er alle
Aspekte dieser Debatte jeweils erfasst
hat und deshalb ist zuhören so wichtig
und aufeinander eingehen und von daher
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Fraktion wäre es schön wenn wir auch das
hören was sie sich denn wünschen und
nicht nur das was sie meinen was an dem
Verfahren nicht gut ist
die Abwägung
über die Impfpflicht ist keine leichter
Entscheidung und es wird immer wieder
das Argument der Freiheitsrechte des
Recht auf körperliche Unversehrtheit
angeführt
wer aber redet eigentlich von dem Recht
auf körperliche Unversehrtheit all der
Menschen die schwerwiegende
Vorerkrankungen haben und deren
teilhaberecht in den letzten zwei Jahren
so massiv eingeschränkt worden sind
sie können jetzt sagen ja ist vielleicht
nicht so relevant ist vielleicht nur
eine kleine Gruppe
weit gefehlt es sind ca 25 bis 30
Prozent in unserer Bevölkerung die
relevante Risikofaktoren haben es ist
also keine kleinen Gruppe
es geht nicht nur um Menschen über 65
und auch das ist schon eine besonders
große Gruppe sondern beispielsweise um
Menschen mit chronischen
Lungenerkrankungen Diabetes oder
Herzerkrankungen
es gibt noch eine Gruppe von Menschen
auf die ich ihre Aufmerksamkeit lenken
möchte die mit sogenannter
Immunsuppression bei denen das
Immunsystem entweder aufgrund einer
Erkrankung oder aufgrund der Behandlung
einer Erkrankung Infektion nicht
entsprechend bekämpfen kann
all diese Menschen sind darauf
angewiesen dass möglichst wenig an
virusherden in unserer Gesellschaft
zirkuliert besonders hart getroffen hat
die Pandemie Familien mit schweren mit
Kindern mit schweren Vorerkrankungen und
Behinderung nicht nur diese Kinder sind
betroffen sondern auch ihre Geschwister
und ihre Eltern viele von denen leben
seit zwei Jahren in Isolation besuchen
nicht mehr die Schule können nicht mehr
teilhaben was ist mit deren Recht auf
Teilhabe an Bildung
was ist mit dem Recht der Kassiererin
die eine schwere chronische
Lungenerkrankung hat und nicht in der
Lage ist acht Stunden mit Maske zu
arbeiten und gleichwohl auf besonderen
Schutz angewiesen ist was sagen wir ihr
denn wenn Kolleginnen sich nicht impfen
lassen kannst du halt nicht mehr
arbeiten gehen hast du halt kein Recht
mehr deinen Lebensunterhalt zu verdienen
das sind die Fragen auf die wir
Antworten finden müssen
alle
von denen ich besprochen habe sind
darauf angewiesen dass wir insgesamt
ruhlebensquoten haben nur dann bleibt
Ihnen die Chance ein Infektion für sich
zu verhindern und aktuell haben sie nur
die Wahl auf entweder Risiko eingehen
oder nicht teil zu haben und es ist das
Virus was uns fehlt vieles wegnimmt und
wir diskutieren darüber wie kommen wir
aus dieser Situation wieder raus und
deshalb komme ich in der Abwägung zu dem
Schluss dass wir eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht ab 18 brauchen denn eine
Impfpflicht die altersbezogen ist die
löst genau das Problem nicht dass wir
nach wie vor Räumen unserer Gesellschaft
haben wo eben viele ungeimpfte Menschen
sind und dann kann sich jemand aus all
diesen Gruppen die ich dargestellt habe
in keinerlei Gruppe aufhalten wo
Menschen unter 50 sind wo viele
ungeimpfte sich aushalten und das ist
für mich die Abwägung der Politik hat
nicht nur die auf
Freiheit als absoluten Begriff zu
verteidigen sondern wir müssen unser
Zusammenleben so gestalten dass wir
möglichst Teilhabe für alle Teilhabe
unserer Gesellschaft garantiert
zu seiner ersten Rede kommt aus der
SPD-Fraktion jetzt zu Wort dr Christos
pantazis
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern von dem
Bildschirm vorneweg ich hätte mir nicht
erträumen lassen können dass ich meine
erste hier im Hohen Hause Rede im Rahmen
orientierungsdebatte zu allgemein
Impfpflicht würde halten dürfen diese
hier und heute miteinander begonnene
Debatte stellt für mich eine Sternstunde
des Parlamentarismus über Parteigrenzen
da und ich bin stolz an dieser
teilnehmen zu dürfen
wie sicherlich viele von ihnen war ich
als Mediziner nach Zulassung gut
getesteter und sicherer Impfstoffe
zunächst kein Anhänger einer allgemeinen
Impfpflicht lange Zeit haben wir
schließlich alle an die
Eigenverantwortung Vernunft und
Solidarität unserer Bürgerinnen und
Bürger appelliert sich freiwillig impfen
zu lassen so dass wir das Ziel einer
hohen impfquoto von 80 bis 90 Prozent
erreichen würden genau diese stellt
nämlich die Grundvoraussetzung da um die
Pandemie zu überwinden und eine stabile
infektionslage zu erreichen nur dadurch
werden wir unsere seit Beginn der
Pandemie konsequent verfolgten Ziele die
Vermeidung der Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystems die Vermeidung von
wirtschaftlichen sozialen sowie
gesundheitlichen Langzeitfolgen wie dem
longkowit erreichen wir müssen
allerdings zur Kenntnis nehmen trotz
diverse Anstrengungen haben wir nach
über einem Jahr des impfstoffeinsatzes
als Weg aus der Pandemie heraus unser
Ziel einer ausreichenden Impfquote auf
diesem Wege letztendlich nicht erreichen
können auch wenn sich ein Großteil der
Bevölkerung hat impfen lassen es bleibt
eine signifikante folgenschwere
impflücke in zweistelliger Millionenhöhe
als Konsequenz sind wir weiterhin mit
pandemischen Wellen konfrontiert die
durch das Risiko der entstehts
Entstehens neuer gefährlicher
Virusvarianten insbesondere
medizinischem Bereich zu wiederkehrenden
Überlastung des Gesundheitssystems
führen können das meine ich genau damit
unsere Intensivstationen sind mit
ungeimpften Patienten überlastet das
medizinische Personal ist nach der nur
mehr vierten Welle ausgelaugt und
Pandemie müde krankenhäuser müssen
planbare Eingriffe auf ungewisse Zeit
verschieben häufig es haben viele
Rednerinnen vor mir auch schon
angesprochen mit gravierenden Folgen für
unzählige Krebspatientinnen und
Patienten die Sorge vor einer Triage ist
insbesondere im operativen Bereich de
facto bereits heute traurige Qualität
sprechen Sie doch mal mit chefärztinnen
der Anästhesie welche Erfahrungen sie
tagtäglich bei der Planung von Operation
erleben dort wird der Mangel verwaltet
es ist mittlerweile zu einer buchwelle
von Operation bekommen die von Tag zu
Tag größer wird
ganz
zu schweigen von den enormen Belastungen
durch eine ständige Wiederkehr von
kontaktbeschränkungen für das
Funktionieren unseres Gemeinwesens und
hier insbesondere meine Vorrednerin hat
es eben gerade zurecht angesprochen für
Kinder und Jugendliche die seit vielen
Monaten im Ausnahmezustand Leben wie
eingangs gesagt ich war kein Anhänger
einer Impfpflicht die Einsicht in den
Notwendigkeit ist bei mir insbesondere
im letzten Dreivierteljahr gewachsen ich
habe quasi eine Lernkurve wenn sie es so
bezeichnen wollen hinter mich gebracht
ich fasse daher zusammen zu Eindämmung
des
gesamtinfektionsgeschehens mit einer
hohen grundimmunität einer Entlastung
unseres Gesundheitssystems sowie so
abwehrwirtschaftlicher sozialer sowie
gesundheitlicher Langzeitfolgen spreche
ich mich hier und heute als Mediziner
aus praktischen und ethischen Gründen
nun für eine allgemeine zeitlich
begrenzte Impfpflicht ab 18 Jahren aus
ich halte diese auch aus den eben
genannten Gründen für erforderlich
angemessen und ja auch verhältnismäßig
um die Pandemie letztendlich zu
überwinden und eine stabile
infektionslage zu erreichen herzlichen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
karsten Müller ist nun der nächste
Redner in dieser Debatte aus der
Unionsfraktion
zum Schluss dieser Debatte sind jetzt
aufgrund der fraktionsgröße nur noch SPD
und Unionsabgeordnete zu hören denn umso
größer die Fraktion umso mehr Redezeit
wird eher zugestanden Komponente meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Kollegen und
Kollegen
wie sie alle bekomme ich in den
aktuellen Tagen eine Vielzahl von
Anrufen Nachfragen Zuschriften wie
hältst du es eigentlich mit der
allgemeinen Impfpflicht
und das ist eine schwierig zu
beantwortende Frage die kann man nicht
einfach mal so mit Ja oder Nein
beantworten ich sage ja in einer
deutlichen Tendenz bin ich eher dafür
aber es kommt darauf an eine Reihe von
Dingen die genannt worden sind wie sie
ausgestellt wird wenn sie erfasst wie
sie sanktioniert wird wie Sanktionen
durchgesetzt werden welche
organisatorischen Maßnahmen dieser Staat
ergreift und meine Damen und Herren es
gibt eine andere Frage die auch gestellt
wird die ist deutlich leichter zu
beantworten
wird die Bundesregierung ihrer
Verantwortung im Moment gerecht nein sie
wird es leider nicht ich will ihnen das
Skizzieren vor welcher Situation
diskutieren wir heute wir haben eine AD
hoc-kürzung der Wirksamkeit des genesen
im Staates auf drei Monate einfach mal
so
merkwürdigerweise setzt dich dieselbe
Bundesregierung die das zu verantworten
hat auf europäischer Ebene jetzt im
Moment für eine
sechs-monatige Wirksamkeit des genesenen
Staates ein das nenne ich erstmal
planlos das führt zu Irritationen meine
Damen und Herren ich möchte bei der
Gelegenheit übrigens auch das Präsidium
bitten insofern die Allgemeinverfügung
die für dieses Hausgeld sehr kurzfristig
anzupassen ich halte das für ein
unerträglichen Zustand
wir erleben eine ebenso überraschende
Abwertung des Impfstoffs von Johnson und
Johnson da sind Leute jetzt plötzlich
nicht mehr vollständig vollständig
geimpft und die haben sich ausdrücklich
nicht gewillkürt für Johnson und Johnson
entscheiden können sondern die haben das
genommen was da war und das war dann in
deren Wellen Johnson & Johnson meine
Damen und Herren der Justizminister
sitzt hier von einer Reihe was macht er
in dieser Zeit er übt sich in regelmäßig
unzutreffenden Prognosen über den
corona-verlauf und er sagt im Register
und eben war die Frage was wünschen sie
sich denn eigentlich im Verfahren im
Register wünsche ich mich halt das für
elementar wichtig Volker Ulrich als
ihnen erklärt eine impfregister das
kommt eher nicht in Frage weil dauert zu
lange da sieht man mal welches zutrauen
ein FDP-Minister in die
digitalisierungskompetenz ist ebenfalls
von der FDP-geführten zuständigen
Ministeriums hat meine Damen und Herren
ich könnte das Verfehlen des
boosterziels aufzählen und ich könnte
Ihnen das Durcheinander mit den Tests
vorhalten wir reden hier heute angeblich
über eine Gewissensentscheidung meine
Damen und Herren nein sie ist es ja
gerade nicht und auch das ist heute
schon gesagt worden sie haben die
sektorale Impfpflicht nämlich
einrichtungs- und berufsbezogen vor
wenigen Wochen hier als nicht
Gewissensentscheidung behandelt das ist
genau derselbe grundrechtseindruck und
was hat sich geändert geändert hat dass
die Ampelkoalition ihre Mannschaft nicht
an Bord hat sie haben keine Mehrheit und
deswegen versuchen Sie sich jetzt etwas
an den Rand zu drücken meine Damen und
Herren das funktioniert so nicht und es
ich will auf einen letzten Punkt
eingehen der Kollege Tino Sorge hat
darauf hingewiesen dass es sich der
Gesundheitsminister denkbar einfach
macht und der Gesundheitsminister hat
gesagt bei Twitter während dieser
Debatte man dürfte das alles
parteipolitisch nicht
instrumentalisieren sie die
Bundesregierung haben eine große Chance
verstreichen lassen
die cdu/csu-fraktion hat einen
detaillierten Fragenkatalog an die
Bundesregierung gerichtet dieser
fragenkatholik umfasst einen Teil der
Fragen die sich jeder in dieser Debatte
stellen muss auch diejenigen die
gruppenanträge verfassen deswegen wäre
es ein Zeichen der überparteilichen
Behandlung diese schwierigen Themas
gewesen wenn Sie eine Antwort geliefert
hätten die Substanz gehabt hätte ihre
Antwort ist verfristet gekommen und sie
erfüllt noch nicht einmal minimale
formale Anforderungen Antworten von
Inhalten ist nichts zu lesen meine Damen
und Herren damit werden sie der
Herausforderung in dieser schwierigen
Zeit als Bundesregierung nicht gerecht
und ich hätte eigentlich erwartet dass
auch andere Redner hier diesen Punkt
auch aus den ampelfraktionen nachgefasst
hatten denn die Antwort geht ja nicht
nur ausschließlich an die Unionsfraktion
sondern an das Parlament und als dieses
diskutieren wir hier heute vielen Dank
Carsten Müller hat hier die
Bundesregierung in die Verantwortung
genommen Karl Lauterbach der
Gesundheitsminister des bundeswirt zwar
hier sprechen allerdings als
Abgeordneter in seiner Funktion als
Abgeordneter vorher hören wir aber noch
Sonja eichwede für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen unser Parlament
ist ein Ort von verantwortungsvollen
Entscheidungen und Debatten wie sie die
demokratischen Fraktionen in diesem Haus
hier heute führen es ist auch eine
wichtige Debatte die wir gerade im
Parlament führen sollten denn sie wird
in der Gesellschaft intensiv geführt
deshalb ist es auch der richtige Ort Sie
hier im Hohen Hause in der Herzkammer
unserer Demokratie zu führen und das
auch gemeinsam zu tun denn es handelt
sich um eine ethische Frage
die demokratischen Fraktionen eint das
Ziel und ich denke da darf ich auch für
die cdu/csu-fraktion und für die linke
Fraktion mitsprechen einen guten
nachhaltigen Weg aus dieser Pandemie zu
finden die Gesundheit des
Gesundheitssystems und die
Daseinsvorsorge in unserem Land zu
schützen denn gerade insbesondere in der
wichtigen Infrastruktur in der Pflege in
der Medizin wurde durch die ständigen
Wellen in den letzten zwei Jahren
Übermenschliches geleistet deshalb muss
es doch jetzt unser Ziel sein vor die
nächste Welle zu kommen mit unserem
Handeln mit dem Vertrauen was uns
übertragen wurde
es geht hierbei um eine erheblich höhere
Impfquote und es geht um eine
Grundimmunisierung die wir brauchen als
rechtspolitikerin möchte ich aber sagen
weil hier insbesondere auch von rechts
bei einigen Wortbeiträgen die
Verfassungsmäßigkeit angesprochen wurde
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht kann
verfassungsgemäß sein das ist auch
mehrmals so festgestellt worden und
natürlich kommt es bei der Ausgestaltung
aber
darauf an wie wir es ausgestalten das
ist bei jedem Gesetz so und das ist auch
wichtig und richtig in einem Rechtsstaat
denn in seinem solchen leben wir
selbstverständlich
um es mit den Worten des
verfassungsrechtlers Professor Dr Franz
Meyer zu sagen mit Erlaubnis der
Präsidentin zitiere ich hinter der
Verfassung können wir uns hier bei
dieser Debatte nicht verstecken
hinsichtlich der Ausgestaltung einer
Impfpflicht kommt es aber auf mehrere
rechtliche Fragen an ich möchte dabei
den Fokus auf zwei Punkte legen nämlich
auf die Zielsetzung der vorgeschlagenen
Modelle und auf die Frage der
Durchsetzung eine Impfpflicht stellt
natürlich einen Grundrechtseingriff zum
Schutz anderer Grundrechte und rechte
mit Verfassungsrang da sie darf nur
aufgrund eines Gesetzes welches ein
legitimes Ziel verfolgt und in der
zweckmittelrelation geeignet
erforderlich und angemessen ist erfolgen
das lernt jeder Jura-Student im ersten
Semester wichtig ist hier bei der Frage
der Erforderlichkeit will ich zu einigen
Debatten beitragen tragen aber sagen
dass es hier nicht nur auf die Frage
eines milderen mittels sondern auf einen
gleichgeeigneten milderen mittels
ankommt
das betrachten wir wiederum bei der
Zielsetzung denn die Zielsetzung in der
Frage eines Schutzes mit einer
Impfpflicht über 50 ist eine Zielsetzung
die insbesondere die wunarablen Gruppen
und die Intensivstation im Blick hat ist
das Ziel aber der Schutz des
Gesundheitssystems und der öffentlichen
darf seines Vorsorge in Gänze wollen wir
vor die nächste Welle kommen und auch in
Schulen Kitas Kultur der Gastronomie und
vielen weiteren Bereichen wieder in
normales Fahrwasser zu kommen ist eine
eine allgemeine innenpflicht mit einer
Befristung ab 18 das aus unserer Sicht
gebotene Mittel
nur dieser Vorschlag bietet durch eine
Steigerung der Impfquote die Chance
unser Gesundheitssystem auch nachhaltig
wieder zu stärken und aus dem
krisenmodus herauszubringen
neben der Pflicht bedarf es aber
insbesondere auch weiterer Aufklärung
wir müssen
Ängste nehmen wir müssen den Legenden
Bildung entgegenwirken denn diese gibt
es auch und wir haben sichere gute
Impfstoffe noch einen Punkt zur
Durchsetzbarkeit hier ist ein
Bußgeldverfahren was auch ein
rechtsstaatliches Verfahren ist ein
Kollege geeignetes Mittel liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Debatte ist
wichtig für unseren Austausch ich möchte
[Musik]
ich komme ich komme zum Ende ich komme
zum letzten Satz das Thema ist zu
wichtig um es zu instrumentalisieren von
daher bitte ich um eine gute weitere
Austausch
dieses Licht da zeigt Ihnen dann schon
an wenn Sie über die Zeit sind
noch ein Hinweis von
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Katrin Göring
Eckert hier Herr Kollege diese nächste
immer sie ging hilft uns in dieser
Debatte aus meiner Sicht nicht weiter
ich gebe das Wort aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion dem Kollegen Dr Georg
kippels
und gehe davon aus dass auch auf der
Tribüne alle ihre Maske tragen Herr
Kollege bitte schön vielen Dank sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen fast am Ende
dieser dreistündigen
orientierungsdebatte geht es darum ein
gewisses Fazit zu ziehen wichtig für den
heutigen Nachmittag ist die Feststellung
dass es ganz überwiegend ein Konsens
gibt dass das Impfen an sich
erstrebenswert ist dass es einen hohen
Nutzen hat und dass wir uns alle darum
bemühen sollten an den großen Teil der
Bevölkerung mit dieser Impfung zu
versorgen das zweite Erkenntnis des
heutigen nachmittags ist dass es auch
ein Entwicklungsprozess gibt denn die
Forderung der CDU CSU-Fraktion zu
Errichtung eines impfregisters hat
jedenfalls in der SPD-Fraktion schon
Berücksichtigung gefunden Frau Kollegin
stammig hat sich ausdrücklich dafür
ausgesprochen ich denke das ist gerade
auch in Ansehung des vierten
Stellungnahme des expertenrates eine
absolut richtige und wichtige die
Erkenntnis dass die wissenschaftliche
Begleitung auf der Grundlage aktueller
Daten eine zwingende Voraussetzung für
die weitere Vorgehensweise ist aber wo
stehen wir jetzt am Ende des zweiten und
am Beginn des dritten corona-jahres ich
denke an einer waren an einer
grundlegenden Änderungen der Strategie
in den letzten zwei Jahren waren wir
darauf verwiesen mit den herkömmlichen
Erkenntnissen der Wissenschaft über
Hygiene Quarantäne Isolation die
Übertragung zu vermeiden und im Rahmen
der Behandlung der Patientinnen und
Patienten die bestmögliche Versorgung
herbeizuführen mit dem was bis jetzt die
Pharmazie zu bieten hat für die Zukunft
gibt es jetzt eine fantastische
Perspektive der häufig heute gelobte
Impfstoff zeigt ganz offensichtlich
Wirkung bei den Patientinnen und
Patienten die Patientinnen Patienten die
heute auf der Intensiv nun liegen sind
nur noch zu einem Drittel geimpft und zu
zwei Dritteln ungeimpft das spricht
dafür dass die schweren Verläufe durch
die Impfung vermieden werden können also
geht es darum nunmehr dieses probate
Mittel weiter anzuwenden und da kommen
wir an die Frage der Grundrechts
Kollision können wir zur Durchsetzung
einer Impfpflicht die
Individualinteressen dem Gemeinwohl
Interesse unterordnen und ich komme in
der Tat zu der Erkenntnis ja das müssen
wir denn wir haben auch in den
vergangenen zwei Jahren ununterbrochen
Grundrechtseinschränkungen vornehmen
müssen und zwar nicht nur von der
Eingriffsintensität selbst sondern auch
in zeitlich qualitativer Hinsicht und es
kann auch dann zu einer
beendigungsnotwendigkeit kommen wenn
ganz einfach aufgrund eines anderen
mittels die dauerhafte Aufrechterhaltung
eines vielleicht leichteren
Grundrechtseingriffs nicht mehr
vertretbar ist und ich denke da muss
dann auch die angebliche Vernunft des
Einzelnen die ja im Prinzip aus Sicht
der Gemeinschaft das unvernünftig
eingestuft werden kann untergeordnet
werden und es gibt dann auch im Rahmen
der grundrechtskollision die
Verpflichtung des Staates die
Einrichtungen des gemeinwohlinteresses
Kindergärten Krankenhäuser Schulen
Senioreneinrichtungen in ihrer
Funktionstauglichkeit und
Leistungsfähigkeit sicherzustellen und
auch die dauerhafte Belastung derjenigen
die dort verantwortungsvoll ihre Arbeit
versehen aufzugeben wir brauchen also
hier und heute eine konsequente
Entscheidung wir brauchen Sie
datenbasiert um auch dauerhaft die
Verhältnismäßigkeit des Vorgehens weiter
nachweisen zu können und wir brauchen
selbstverständlich auchkeit auch eine
schnellere Reaktion insofern kann ich
mich nur sehr schwer mit dem Vorschlag
der vorgeschalteten Pflichtberatung
auseinandersetzen dennoch jetzt ist ja